on to see the seventh day and we have
some bills coming up here in which we
got to exec
um I'd also like to welcome represent
tenzer and Priests here who are standing
in for folks which are not here today
you're going to really enjoy being on
the education committee for a day and
probably very pleased when you can get
out of here
um
uh it's always very interesting where we
end up
um as a mentioned to everybody here on
the committee there are a number I
mentioned it to uh the caucus which I
had in here but I want to also identify
that we have a number of bills going on
today in division two which are House
Education bills which we're going to be
popping in and out on so we're going to
have to be cognizant of that and and
folks are out there we're going to try
to hold off till we get people back so
if somebody is going to do some
testifying in there please let them know
over there and have them send you a text
message when you're either on deck or
ready to add that to do your
presentation at that at the hearing
there
um
so and secondly we do have a work
session coming up scheduled for Friday
on school building Aid anybody on this
committee is welcome to attend that
division two is coming into it we also
have a doe participating in that we're
looking at the funding process for
school building Aid in the application
process with timeline which also needs
to have a lot of work and we do have a
bill 452 dealing with that we're trying
to get a work session in prior to our
having to take action on that bill on
next week
and next week is the last week and we
have to get these uh all these exact
sessions done of which you know we're
we're honing in and I think we're about
three quarters the way there on our
exact sessions uh however we have a
number uh this week and next week
um so again uh thank you very much for
getting committee reports in yesterday
they came in in a timely manner in fact
Lindsay is now uh transcribing or typing
all those things into the calendar or
preparing them to go to the speaker
um we got them all that's that's a first
for this committee getting them all in
on the same day that we requested they
come in the same thing I'd like to see
today so if there's a minority or a
majority or uh some other type of report
on these bills I'd like to have those
brought to us uh today so we can stay on
top of this we are meeting again
tomorrow
um and then next week on bills
um so with that I'd like to open up the
exact session any comments about what I
just mentioned or oh yes representative
Cascade just a question will Friday
subcommittee work be on um broadcast
live or
will we be able to watch it it'll be
right in this room so it will be yes it
will be thank you yeah yeah and it's
critical I've spoken with folks in uh
division two and they're really anxious
to really delve into this topic and I'm
sure you're hearing about this on your
local area so if you're a school
district that's trying to get building
eight and you're like seventh or eighth
down the list you're just not going to
get it and you may have a very critical
need and so there's a lot we have to
address
um going on down to the uh calendar for
today we have hb204 relative to
non-academic surveys in schools and I
like to recognize representative Belcher
from emotion
thank you Mr chair I would like to
motion ought to pass
is there a second second okay the
emotions were made by uh represent
Belcher second by representative
cordelli OTP on
hb204 representative Belcher recognized
for discussion thank you Mr chair
um I'll just
um kind of run over the reminder that
this this bill is really a very minor
change is only I believe three new words
added and the bill
um it does nothing at all to affect or
modify the ability of teachers to
maintain normal human relationships with
their students to understand the needs
and the feelings of their students their
individual situations the only thing it
seeks to prohibit is the surveying
through digital
um and physical means of students
emotional states along with the other
things that are already law and the
reason I think we need to do this is we
we need to begin to differentiate
um a little better between schools as
educational facilities police and mental
health facilities as being primarily
Health Care Facilities
um and they they're not something that
need to be combined into the same unit
we need to keep schooling separate thank
you
foreign
Elli do you have any further discussion
I'd just add that um initially I was
wondering about emotional response but I
think it's in line with uh some of the
uh other uh criteria in the last section
um it's not much different than uh
social behave Behavior so I am
supportive of this
further discussion on the committee
represent miler
thank you Mr chair I guess my concern
about this is that
um I think it's a hard line to draw here
if a teacher is working with a student
and they identify that there are some
issues here
we just say oh we're not going to deal
with that
I mean you look at the amount of time
that a student
um
there ought to be an opportunity for
professionals
that deal with kids to identify that and
then then to basically help them deal
with those issues so I guess I totally
disagree with the representative Belcher
on this because uh it's not a medical
they're not MediCal folks so it's kind
of like you know I would assume I don't
know anything about EMTs
but I would assume that there's a
certain amount of stuff that EMTs can do
before they pass it over
to a medical professional
the same thing here with teachers I mean
if they see that there's a problem
that a child has an emotional problem a
child has they're clearly not they're
not
the ultimate person who's going to deal
with that issue but then they pass it
over to the counselor
or they move it someplace else
but to say here oh no you can't deal
with this
I just think it's absurd frankly I like
to just have a word here um I'm looking
at this in terms of non-academic survey
or questionnaire not as a EMT or a
counselor working specifically with a
student that's not a survey that's not a
question questionnaire that's one-on-one
or working collaboratively to address
what may be perceived as an issue and
have discussion
um so I see it as relating to like the
youth risk behavior survey and I see a
question on the uterus survey that
really kind of concerns me as question
number 24 this is the New Hampshire
survey it says during the past 12 months
how many times did someone you were
dating or going out would purposely try
to control you or emotionally hurt you
all right so we already have emotionally
in the youth risk behavior survey
um is that a proper question to be
asking if in fact it was you know this
were passed it would not be a proper
question because it is in the
questionnaire it's in the survey and
we're talking about emotions
so uh represent Belcher
thank you for that Mr chair I would note
that the the CDC survey is is continues
to be Exempted uh so I didn't remove
that particular survey but yes other
surveys was questions like that
um would not be uh allowable under this
but just to address the concerns that
were raised I think it goes in a very
different direction it's
um it's a very different argument to
have and it has nothing to do with this
bill really that that student or rather
that teacher should be able to
coordinate with parents to obtain proper
mental health for students who have
issues that that's a very different
argument to have but this bill does
nothing to address that this bill is
just about surveys it's just about
asking students either in physical or
digital format about emotionally probing
questions that parents have come to me
with and said they're not comfortable
with these questions just being asked
without their permission of of their
children
um so there's nothing that would
prohibit
um
having a student with a problem receive
proper Mental Health Care under this uh
under this bill represent cascaden do
you have your hand up earlier
thank you I could not agree with you
more that education and school systems
are for education
but if you look back 10 to 15 years how
many laws have been passed by
legislation
to impose more and more social services
within the school district it's it's
overwhelming and that's when you get
down to having to pick and choose what
do you do
I don't think there's a need for this
bill honestly because we are required to
provide social emotional learning and
we're supposed to be teaching kids now
did they eat did they not eat how do
they feel and eat how are they feeling
when they don't eat I mean is there
substance abuse in the home with
somebody in the home last night how all
of these social things that belong in
the home to be dealt with by a parent
are dumped on the school system when
that kid walks through the door
um what I'm concerned about in this bill
um you know even with drug and alcohol
education I mean that's a law that you
have to provide that
um I don't think there's a need for this
bill
until you start taking and repealing all
the social issues that have been plugged
represent cordelli and represent Damon
uh thank you
um I I agree with you representative
um and a lot of that has come from the
federal government
um in terms of was Essa
um
the last well-round and No Child Left
Behind
required a large part of that with the
emotional learning Etc
um required of States uh to be done
and yeah concerned about back then and I
think it's a concern for all of us
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair
I want to remind all of us that this
bill is about surveys that the data is
aggregated it is not about individual
student data
Egret survey data is science that's used
to drive knowledge and programming I see
no valuable purpose to this bill I think
that if we don't collect data on the
well-being of students we don't know how
to proceed
in terms of meeting their educational
needs you can't learn if you're not
reasonably mentally well thank you
for the representative uh pettinellen
then reps out I just wanted to point out
to representative cascadin that the part
that she was
um
taking
uh not a fence the right word objection
to was is already part of Statute the
other dot or other documents is part of
statute
represent cascadden um I guess my
question would be a lot of schools will
do culture and climate surveys so they
can get a pulse beat on how kids are
feeling in the environment because
obviously that makes a difference
this bill would prevent that
and don't you want to measure
if if kids feel safe if they know who to
go to
um that's a big piece of having a
healthy school environment
further discussion represent uh Rye
dry excuse me thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you again I'm a little
confused because this is about
it's not about getting rid of the survey
it's about your sub your participation
in it there's nothing here that forbids
a school from doing any of these surveys
it is how you participate and it goes
through the parents first and they're
allowed to look at it and they can give
their permission and
students can do it and emancipated
minors can do it on their own the survey
perhaps and Damon
in response to what representative drive
in survey work if you don't survey
as much of the population as you can you
don't collect the same data
so
more that we make it likely
that not as many students will
participate the less credible the data
is
representative leckis
I remember a lot of objection from
teachers when various of the social
emotional learning came out there was
social emotional learning that didn't
involve surveys and keeping track and
all of that kind of stuff but they're
ones and one of the schools that was in
my district
I heard from parents and teachers and
went and actually sat in on an open
house to find out exactly what they were
doing and they were doing these physical
surveys with the little kids
tapping how they felt but they had to
record them and track them and all that
kind of stuff and the teachers kept
saying this isn't my job I'm not a
health care professional this isn't what
I should be doing and you don't have to
do that to do social emotional learning
but some programs you do and they
actually have teachers taking surveys of
the kids and recording it and keeping
data and all of that and so this is if a
parent says no I don't want you doing
that to my kid they can say no don't do
that to my kid I mean that's it's kind
of a protection of the teachers as well
as the students
because yeah we're piling as you said
more and more and more on teachers that
it's not what they're supposed to be
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair I just want to make two quick
points first I want to correct I think a
small thing that was perhaps there
um
um there's nothing in this that would
get surgery between disaggregated data
surveys versus normal surveys and the
CDC is still under this authorized to
conduct their yearly survey but I would
also uh harken back my my own testimony
on this bill that we are entering a new
phase of Cutting Edge education where
we're seeing algorithmically driven
artificial intelligence data mining
children through Google through other
big programs creating things such as
little digital friends that they can
communicate with in order to apply
um something that's called nudge Theory
which is developed by British
psychological warfare experts in order
to actually change the way that children
are thinking about ideological and
values-based things and these are really
items that are controversial and a lot
of parents don't want to see this thing
done
that's one line
well that's too bad because it should be
common practice
I mean it's my perception that happens
where most of the places have happened
and it's not
it's not a problem it's not happening
somewhere it's an Administration problem
if somebody needs to get on board and
take care
um representative
um you could just make sure the chords
are plugged in properly into the back of
your mic and test your mic again
all right
I've notified them upstairs
a representative Noble
thank you
um it it does happen
um without parental consent because it
did happen to my child and it's because
they were doing an online test and the
survey was at the end so she couldn't
complete her test without doing the
true okay any further questions
or comments
can see none we have the chairman
upstairs in the Senate so um we'll hold
off on a vote on that
um Bill until uh we have a full
complement of members so um let's uh
open up the discussion on uh House Bill
267 School background checks
uh criminal record checks in school
employment
and uh call upon representative try for
emotion
if you want a motion then it's ought to
pass
thank you is there a second oh second
second representative
um representative dry do you have uh
so this bill is an enabling Bill and it
doesn't
um
require it just allows uh school
administrative units school districts or
chartered public schools to do more than
just the initial criminal history
records check when someone is hired I
mean we may have seen recently in the
paper a case of someone who was in one
District committed a crime moved to
another District committed the same
crime perhaps that would be something
that would turn up in a
an employee situation it's enabling
legislation it just allows this and it's
a group of employees so that no person
is singled out for any kind of
vindictness or or any any kind of
signaling out singling out for
um a records check so uh in the fact
that this doesn't make any requirements
but does open a door and certainly it's
a policy on many school levels but we
would like to codify it that's why I'm
its motion is ought to pass
thank you further comments
representative Myler
I just have a question perhaps somebody
can answer for me is that when
when I get my initial
check
I pay for that it's about forty eight
dollars fifty dollars
if the school district asks for another
check who pays for that
does anybody have the answer to that
is it the school district is it the
individual
represent Tanner
thank you
um I have a couple concerns with this uh
number one the group
portion of it that is supposed to
protect the individual well in a lot of
schools you know there's one art teacher
one school nurse one third grade teacher
uh maybe even you know one uh language
teacher and um
so groups don't won't cover uh the
individual and I think that this bill
could lead to some
um unintended consequences of someone uh
wanting to dismiss a teacher not
necessarily for a criminal
problem
but
um using it as a way of harassment
um and the other thing is that I would I
would think that um at least when I was
teaching uh what happened was that every
time you went for uh the three year or
five-year renewal you also went through
a background check which I think is
um sufficient
thank you
you're absolutely no thank you very much
Mr chair so um
the
um the the new language here in the in
the bill certainly uses the word Public
School A Charter Public School or School
District may choose to require however
um this this isn't really typical of of
enabling legislation enabling
legislation is sort of like Senate Bill
2 from uh from you know 15 20 years ago
that would allow a school district or or
a town municipality to decide a town
meeting if they're going to use standard
town meeting or a deliberative session
and and and have votes this clearly
um would um would would allow uh public
schools in fact it would require public
schools to um to uh to be able to
negotiate terms into a collective
bargaining agreement that would um that
would uh allow the public school to uh
to perform
uh more frequent or recurring uh
background checks on any group of
employees so it's not really enabling it
really puts it into the the next
collective bargaining
um uh contract as a as a negotiating
item and I think as part of that the uh
the the the the negotiating
um uh item uh might include things like
what representative Miler was talking
about who's going to pay for the checks
how often are the criminal checks uh
going to happen uh to um uh for what
groups of uh of employees and uh and I
think it's it's that phrase any group of
employees where where this gets murky
very quickly whether that is as
representative Tanner has suggested
could be used to um to uh potentially
discriminate or or provide you know
challenges to uh to to certain groups of
of employees
um
on on
any basis
you know whatsoever the the the
legislation is not uh uh specific on
that uh on that at all but um but you
know that set all of that said I think
there was some some good reason that was
um that was uh put forward by the
superintendent Goffstown that that that
they're they're I think there's some
value in doing this I'm not sure this
specific language is really the right
language to um
um to to to move forward and um in fact
I was I was hoping we'd have some sort
of mutual you know amending language on
this that that would sort of roll in the
uh the the the the interests of um of is
it superintendent bulky
um
Brian balke in in Goffstown and also
address I think some of the concerns
that Captain Muzzy
um uh shared and that we could actually
have something that uh you know
something that's really positive comes
that comes out of this I'm I'm sort of
disappointed we we but you know when we
got 100 bills to work on right it's it's
hard to necessarily fix fix everything
in time but but I you know I'm I I can't
support uh to passing you know an OTP
you know as it is right now
um uh I I really love it I think if we
could retain this bill and and and do
something do something with it
um
you know I think criminal uh Records
checks are important and um uh not just
for for public for all public schools
but uh but really across the board
um in uh in any situation where where
where you know an adult is going to be
in a um uh be with uh with a child or or
multiple multiple children so I think
there's I think there's value in here I
just hope we could work on the language
um resident Belcher maybe you want to
try your mic again
testing testing okay there we go thank
you
um
so with this bill I see it down the road
unless there have been a Scholars
attached to it's not quantitative so I
um the question also raised to you is
so it does give autonomy to the school
district under any reasonable suspicion
a group of employees is
does not fit
does not fit the language
um
so I would like to say something
that gives autonomy to be able to
prevent a teacher from going from one
District to the next
so there are mechanisms I can tell you
as a superintendent to go test a student
in another District representative
I had to have another full criminal
record check after just the retired year
it worked in another District so every
District
whether you're a licensed educator
or you work you add criminal background
checking for your previous position in
the school system you are required to
get a remote records check for each
individual District you work
just clarification and
you'd like to see something
foreign
how this is an unfunded mandate when
it's not a mandate it says may choose
and may choose is is about as
free and open as wording I can think of
that's the opposite of a child you may
choose to do this if you want to we're
giving permission that's all that is and
then my next part of that is a question
how would you word instead of any group
of employees to to make sure that it
you're not
um
going after an individual
what what wording you know if we can fix
free
thank you
thank you chairman cordelli
um I don't we reiterate just a few
things that Roy even said I have a
couple pieces I thought the
superintendent of Goffstown was uh
purposeful I thought it was direct and
he came with a reason his reason was if
you recall that he had uh 10-year not
tenured long-term employees who came
there before he did before the
background checks were part of the
current apparatus for uh hiring and he
has no way to check them
that's his concern the problem he had
with the collective buying agreement
didn't allow him to go back and check
the the status of the folks and that's
legit but that's why they have a
collective buying agreement and that's
why they haven't got a union to do that
to work with that I think he has a right
to know every single employee in that
school has been back on check everybody
that works for the youngster I don't
care where they work with a youngster
she have a background check at least the
first level let us know what we're doing
and as the superintendent said clearly I
have coached in multiple school with
them in a principal vanilla every time I
walk over different school another
background check another 66 bucks
um but that that being said I I have
concerned about two things but I think
the attack was terrific I think we have
to figure out a way to do that and this
this build could be reworked to figure
that out the hypothesis group
um if the intent of the person asking
for the group is not uh above board or
has a premonition or has a bias that
changes how you select the group there's
no definition of group it could be all
the teachers on the first floor that
first floor in that school there's no
discipline going on the teacher's not
doing crap over there I'm going to
recheck the whole first floor that's my
group
we don't have to find a group I think
that's key the second part is we don't
say who can do that school district who
in the school district could do that the
Charter Public School who can ask for
that
so I I think the intent of this bill is
terrific but I don't think we have it
finalized the way we really need it and
for those couple of pieces
um I I well I like the I like the bill
like the intent because no one should be
in school no one should be working with
kids probably back on check but uh I
can't support this the way it is because
I think it has too much bias potential
and I think it can be corrected to reach
what that guy was trying to get to that
everyone in that school should be
checked so as a stand I'd be happy to
work with someone uh on retain or uh we
work or bring back but I can't support
it uh as a OTP as it is uh chairman
cordelli thank you representative
thank you Mr Vice chair
um responding to representative lakers's
question about how would you revise it
and I don't think this is the complete
language that doesn't address the
definition of a group but I think an
amendment that says something like
nothing in this law shall be used to
require an individual to have a records
check distinct from the group calendar
would address some of the concerns that
are being raised that you can't say I
want to know
you know that this person and Target
that person so I would concur with the
suggestion that we retain it it seems
like
there's a lot of concern that needs to
be addressed and also a lot of support
for being more complete in the kids
safety
thank you
thank you any further representative
luno
thank you very much Mr chair and um and
you know I think representative Damon
brings up a really important Point
offers uh you know a suggestion but but
I think
retaining this would allow more people
to sort of offer suggestions I think
represent Damon has a good one but there
may be others as well
um uh you know coming from the school
administrators Association uh uh
possibly coming from other associations
as well but also I think very important
was a point that that um that Captain
Muzzy and Ms J
um mentioned that that really before
even after you know even if this is in
law uh final approval really comes from
the FBI which which which have to take a
look at and um and before anything is
done is subject to their final Authority
when it comes to
um to doing this kind of thing and I
think as representative Woodcock has
mentioned there's a lot of you know
question about what's being meant for
this or could be interpreted different
ways uh um and you know I think having
having some sort of mutual you know
amendment that that that can be
developed with the stakeholders involved
but also and and I think Captain Muzzy
said well you know the FBI doesn't
necessarily pre-approve uh things but we
could take a look at what other states
have done and what other approved
language
um has been done and really you know get
to get to the bottom of this and and get
something that that you know we can we
can put forward in a in a fashion that
meets everybody's needs including um
um uh superintendents including teachers
including teachers that that uh that
applied for employment prior to criminal
background check requirement and um and
also holds muster with the FBI
I'm worried about a superintendent
nature
but if they suspect or have evidence
for information
suspicion for someone
are they going to say no I'm not going
to choose to do that it's my choice
[Music]
for somebody in a position while the
wife
of two sleep
could be is required to do it if there's
something
but I like the idea of that group of
people who've never been from a veterans
and then everybody's done
representative try
thank you Ms chern uh maybe
representative cascad you could help me
out if we said if there was a lot of
apparently a lot of thought of tying
this to the re-licensing uh and that
that would be then that wouldn't exclude
anyone and it wouldn't single anyone out
is that something that we could do in
statute or does that need to be part of
a collective bargaining agreement in a
school district
I believe you can do that in statute
I wouldn't you know that's what I'm
suspecting because then the collective
bargaining will have to follow the laws
okay thank you if you're talking about
recertification I I think that the
department has is looking into that
um doing background checks as part of
recertification
um there's a study committee right too
yes representative right
representative Cornell Thank You does
anyone know what year criminal
the notes I have say in 1993 was enacted
in 2000 it was only some exceptions and
2017 the statute team and uh was more
comprehensive and then in 2018 it became
Russia Tanner so not to date myself too
much
but
um
I started teaching Back in 1970 and I
remember getting
background checks in fact we even had to
have a chest x-ray at the time because
of tuberculosis
um
so I think it's been going on a long
time I I also want to mention that let's
say you're a superintendent
and and
if you have people that have not had
background checks that's kind of on you
and on your school district because in
statute every hire every substitute
every bus driver every
um person who's a designated volunteer
uh
has anybody that's working with kids in
a public school system upon hiring has
to undergo the background checks at this
point so let's say you have Mr Jones uh
that you suspect is doing some foul play
if this is what it's actually intended
the consequence of this if you do a
background check unless he's been caught
and arrested which you probably would
know right away
the background checks are not going to
tell you anything because they only tell
you after the fact after somebody's been
arrested and convicted
um a few years ago they they had a
problem at a school district where and I
uh near me
um where a person had been convict had
been found
yes found guilty of uh assault within a
school district and actually
um
did a negotiation to get it down to a
misdemeanor which then wasn't carried
over to the next school that that person
went to and I was trying to look in the
in the section I know that that's been
addressed in the criminal background
check section of 189 uh in our in our
statute book but I just didn't it's got
tons of annotations if anyone would care
to read through it but I think we really
need to have somebody
do some work on this bill and you know
criminal background checks are like I'm
really think that anybody that works
with kids uh in an educational setting
needs to have one so
I I would vote for retain if if I recall
the employment background checks that
the district does they get a complete
picture
including misdemeanors now so that those
types of situations could be could be
caught representative luno thank you and
and and and I think that's that's it's
an important thing to know that that
this is called a criminal history
records check so not only does it
include
um
um misdemeanors and felonies where where
someone has been found guilty but also
where someone has been found not guilty
um
and um and also it's it's I believe it's
multi-state and that's why the FBI is
involved there's also such a thing as a
New Hampshire only criminal records
check and um
um and that is something that I don't
think this this bill is is about but but
um and and potentially that goes back
you know further in time than than when
this um uh was on I believe anybody can
um can
um fill out paperwork to get a New
Hampshire only uh uh criminal uh
background check but uh but for the for
the multi-state only certain authorized
uh uh officials authorized by law and
subject to the uh the approval of the
FBI can can have access to these records
I think that's why you know why why Dr
cascadden talks about the difficulty in
the portability of these from District
to District because they're not portable
um so so on uh you know the more I think
we we've we've you know debated and
talked about this and um and and and
then one of the comments from
representative Corvette cordelli
um made me remember the um the the study
the the representative McGuire's study
committee that really is looking at it
what what is it with these criminal
background check I mean sorry criminal
history record checks and how can they
be more effective and how can they be
used properly that that I think all the
more reason to uh to retain this and um
and and work closely with with that with
that committee that I'm not even sure if
it's been named of uh I I think
representative Ladd and I looked at this
maybe shortly after the the hearing back
in January and um and we weren't able to
find any any record of it being named
but uh but there's a lot to this and and
um and I and there's a lot of people I
think with with with interest and and
working on that
um you know based on the number of bills
that we had that were in this area last
session uh culminating with
representative McGuire's
um Bill to hey let's study this so
anyway that's all I got there okay thank
you
um representative Woodcock then maybe
we'll um actually there's a question of
you chair sure
um in your dialogue with you and
representative luno I just wanted to
follow up on those I'd written the
question I heard it uh on the uh you
said that the uh department is working
now and I'm assuming maybe as the
committed representative Luna was
talking about uh do you know if if the
part of that over overreach is going to
also include those that are grandfather
without realize the thing or research
um with that go back and and uh handle
the concern that the superintendent from
godstone had that those that never had
an initial you know if that's in there
um if
it represent a fort
thank you Mr chair one issue I would
like to raise in this discussion is
one issue I would like to raise in this
discussion it's been touched on in
various ways but you need to think about
it very specifically and several of you
have had the positions of supervising
groups of people schools whatever and
it comes down to
unsubstantiated substantiated
allegations and things like that which
when they get into school go from one
end to the other like that and how do
you quell them and you plow them with
information accurate honest information
some come in and said Mr Ford did such
and such over in that town last weekend
it was terrible and he ought to be fired
how do you find out
it will go around the school go home
come to the school board and be back out
on the street before your principal or
superintendent or president or whatever
has a chance to call the police station
find out because that would be a
background check in some will form or
another
and you need to have as a manager the
ability to manage the people you're
responsible for
enough thank you
um if there I think we've uh had a good
discussion on on this bill uh
um but uh again we'll uh hopefully
representative Ladd will be uh back soon
so maybe in the meantime
um I'd like to move to uh House Bill 427
uh relative public comment and inquiry
during school board meetings
um
and yes
um and I will uh
I do have an amendment that I would like
years
so as this is going around
um a number of us had talked about this
um original bill
um and had questions about uh some of
the things in the bill the uh
asking of questions of board members
during public comment uh requiring
answers requiring answers within a
certain period of time
Etc
um
so as a reaction to that and the
conversations I had I came up with uh
this amendment that basically replaces
the bill
um and simply
does a couple of things right now the
current statute says the public comment
period shall be for no less than 30
minutes
um I think we had a lot of discussion
when we first heard this bill last year
about that requirement
um what I uh went ahead and indicated
was that public comment periods should
be
allowed so that the public could address
items on the agenda before they're
actually voted on taken up by the board
and also non-agend items could be the
subject of a public comment and I know
in some cases that has not been the case
I revised the 30-minute requirement to
allow earlier completion if there was no
public comment
um and that speakers uh be given three
minutes
um to uh to speak
similar to some of our ground rules here
in the house so um
the bill and the amendment are open for
represent Balboni oh yes thank you it's
regarding the amendment
um
it says uh you have public comment
periods shall be provided for public
input for agenda items before board
action is taken and shall also be
provided for non-agendant items of
community interest
um and then it says each public comment
period is your thought in this bill that
I know having been on a school board
there's multiple items on the agenda
that are action items I use trying to
say that any time before you actually
take a vote for each individual item
that you would have to have a public
comment period
um yeah that wasn't my intent to say
that I think a public comment period at
the beginning of the meeting as you know
some some board some uh do
um to address any coming agenda item
would be sufficient but I know
um in a prior District where I was they
they did have public comment before each
uh
um agenda item that was to be uh acted
upon so I think that would be a local
decision by the school board
representative Luna thanks
um yeah the question on the amendment is
this does this require school boards to
hold two public comment periods each of
no less than 30 minutes or could um
could all of those comments both on
agenda items and other items be um uh be
done in one common period of no less
than 30 minutes
I I think that would be a board option
representative cascadden
thank you
um I guess I question why we need this
bill or amendment when school districts
have local policies that address that
and I would think that uh
school board meeting in one town is
going to differ from one in the city
um based on what their culture and
climate is and so I think it should be
left up to the local school board
because their policies are be in the B
section bdeh is one of them that kind of
clarifies
um how they want people to behave so
that's their prerogative like their
choice on how they want to run their
meetings
without being told how to run their
meetings because you know how local
control they like to do things their way
in lines 25 26 27 28 is very concerning
in light of
the
um disruption of some public entities at
public meetings where members of the
public May file a complaint to the
commissioner of the Department of
Education so that puts him in a
a position of having to control
and discipline people
and when it's not his role his role is
an educational leader
um
so I don't see where that belongs there
either but I really think because the
culture is so different in each
Community the way that we in my school
board meetings with my chair is
definitely not going to be the way that
some of these any of your towns do just
because that's the way we do things
um so I I think that's where it needs to
be left
and thank you I just mentioned it in the
original bill that section you referred
to
um was was one of the concerns that we
tried to address with this amendment by
removing that yeah
um you ask why we need this
I can tell you that we
are from numerous different communities
and including one senator who had a very
similar Bill to this because her
community was not allowing people to
speak and if and their communities that
only allowed them to speak at the very
end which means all votes have already
been taken before they even get input
from the constitu you know from the
townspeople so
that's why because I take it from things
that you've said and things that I know
that you ran a pretty good District
but you can't assume that on all
districts in the state there are some
that do not run as well as you ran yours
just a comment it's disappointing to
know that the leaders in those districts
whether it's town or city
are not allowing that
a resident Damon it's very dis it's very
thank you Mr chair
as I read it I think the amendment
vastly improves on the original Bill and
addresses all of the concerns I
originally had
and I personally do see purpose for the
spill precisely because of the
difference in the way boards and
communities operate and having been in
communities where
public participation was
definitely not welcomed and hard to
provide
I think we do need this policy
but the amendment version of it thank
you representative woodcock thank you
chair cordelli um a couple of pieces uh
clearly historically we know that the
issue arose over the last couple years
through the masking covert I mean that's
the elephant on the table that's where
all this came from it didn't come from a
typical Schoolboy mayor Temple day at
Temple school town over the last 20
years for the most part
um uh but the reality is I I think if
the amount hasn't been put in right it's
just I mean it's like it's a discussion
but you haven't actually correct okay
okay I I agree with representative Damon
that the amendment's a whole lot better
than the original could really concise
um I do I do have one surprise and I do
have one concern about it however
um and and that is the part that talks
about
non-agenda items of community interest
uh I say that for two reasons
um one that one it doesn't
it opens the door to anything
uh by anyone and not necessarily School
related
um and having uh
our uh meeting tomorrow tomorrow night
in Conway I'm sure there'll be several
non-school related items uh uh there but
Mike that's my concern uh rather than
cordelli in the amendment uh if we if
that pot wasn't there it makes a whole
lot of uh think to me and I think that
representative leak is a point about the
the public comment after the Bill's
already been voted what Gazette you know
I agree with I think that a good job on
this client I just like that that pile
of non-agenda items of Q AHS that really
really makes me nervous because that
opens the door for all kinds of things
happening uh in that in that meeting it
has nothing to do with the school policy
I think the fact that is on the agenda
absolutely which is an open door or
anything is that's just me thank you
representative Tanner
thank you I I totally agree that I think
um you know the the issues that we've
seen the bills that have come through
about school board meetings and trying
to control school boards has been in a
direct uh reaction
to the covet and masking and vaccination
vaccinations and
um the brouhaha that came in many many
local school boards I know my local
school board used to meet in the music
room in a nice small area there were
people that came that were rude
sometimes but for the most part it was
you know a well-run meeting
I went after covet when we were meeting
again I go it's now in the gymnasium
where the school board is probably
almost as far away as that back wall uh
from the seating area where the the
public sits and they have microphones
now with somebody there Manning the
microphones to make sure that you know
people have a chance to talk it's it's
really
um
I think caused a lot of communities a
lot of struggle a lot of angst and I
think that as Dr casterian has said
you know our communities are all
different and they have to just like the
select men's meetings are all different
uh when you have you know 500 people in
your town versus you know thousands tens
of thousands you're going to have a
different meeting and a different venue
and I think it's local control I think
we have to let the local community do it
and when there's a problem like there
isn't
some places
um an election's coming up next week and
I think that election is going to uh be
the people's voice on electing people to
the school board that
um hopefully they've the the people in
the community have voiced their opinion
very strongly and I think they have in
some about how poorly the school board
meetings have been run and things will
change that's how democracy works and
because we have local control and
because we have our community public
schools with local
elected officials I I think the more
hands off we can be the better off I
don't think prescribing three minutes a
speaker
um is in our purview or should be thank
you
thank you uh represent Belcher thank you
Mr chair I would I would just want to
get to the heart of this a little bit I
think what we're really looking at here
is the is the right of the people to
petition their government for grievances
that is right they have by the
Constitution
if their local school board is not
giving them that adequate access to them
they then have the right to come to a
higher level such as us to see if we can
correct that
now I think this is actually a very
light touch on the issue and I hope to
assuage some of the concerns that have
been brought up about things getting out
of hand with unscheduled public comment
because this still prescribes the local
school board the ability to limit
to three minutes per person and it has
the ability to limit the 30 minutes
overall for a public comment period so
we're not going to get way out of whack
with this this is actually significantly
preserving local control while providing
just that small amount of ability for
people to have that right to petition
their local school board for grievances
thank you representative Ford
I just like to remind everyone in this
conversation or frequently overlooked
fact that local control is subject to
all state and federal law
you're not free to do anything you want
under local control you have to abide by
state and federal law
given that you have local control
and that's not to say that some groups
don't sometimes push the edges of that
and again some of the members of the
community get exercised and then polite
granted that it's hard to control
thank you representative cascadden did
now
thank you very much Mr chair I'd like to
address where representative Ford
um uh talked about with respect to local
control and being subject to um to state
and federal law so let's say this let's
say the amendment here was to um uh to
become law I mean I do agree that the
amendment is less onerous than the bill
but would that mean that that that that
that
I either as a school board member or a
member of the public that may be in the
meeting would need to sit through up to
30 minutes listening to at a minimum
three minute bytes of people spewing
anti-vaxx messages anti-master it's all
about book bands anti-trans comments
stuff like that that I need to um to sit
through and hear it and if I was board
chair that I would uh I would be limited
be prevented by state law from um uh
from uh interrupting and stop thing
these sorts of vile comments
um I don't know if I
say the masking comments were uh were
vile what about anti-trans comments
um I I think that the board chair would
have a discretion
um uh with any personal comments like
that but um current law is that
current law is that uh the uh comment
period is no less than 30 minutes so
it's a base base amount what the
amendment does is say and if there is no
public comment uh Beyond 10 minutes they
can go on to the next agenda item but Mr
chair what what this is really doing
though is is requiring the the school
board to to not to not limit comments to
just agenda items uh but but include
non-agenda items which as represented
Woodcock has said opens the door wide
open to anything I want to talk about
including spewing anti-trans anti-lgbtq
rhetoric and every board member every
administrator and everybody there and
everybody watching is going to have to
sit through that in in minimum
three-minute chunks up to no up to um to
a half hour and and restrict because
it's state law restrict the board
chair's ability to to rein in that
meeting and those comments
I I I don't think that we are going to
uh to see that I don't think that uh
public comment periods now
um couldn't someone get up during a
public comment period now and spew all
sorts of things now I don't see any
difference from what happens now to
what's proposed in this legislation uh
representative excuse me representative
Belcher can stop it but thank you Mr
chair
and I I I'm not sure I I I'm in reality
because I have to say this but yes we we
members of government
do have to sit there and listen to
whatever the public wants to say if it's
not a violation of Law and we have to
take it
oh representative Tanner
thank you I just I guess I want to go
back to the redress of grievances uh
issue and that the fact that the public
school board meeting is a public
business meeting
and
um the school board at and I'm I'll be
really surprised if this is that the
school board members and the school
board as as a whole has the ability to
accept written complaints written
petitions
um can be spoken to on a on a private
basis
what this is doing is allowing a public
forum
attack address
the school board rather than go through
uh if they have a legitimate complaint
um or just like here I mean people can
come and testify they can also put it on
uh
line they can send us emails I mean who
doesn't get 100 emails
um you know you you have all different
ways to do it you don't have to
reach down to the local level
give a one-size-fits all for the whole
state of New Hampshire where you have
rural areas urban areas you've got
different areas of the state with all
kinds of different culture
to prescribe something like this I I
really
you know don't like the heavy hand
so
um I I think there may be some way to to
address this but basically I don't think
this is where we should be
thank you representative cascadden
uh thank you I still hung up on that 30
minutes of something that you said
Representatives if there's nobody
at your meeting then you can proceed but
you really can't because yep excuse me
you have to publish your your meeting
agenda 24 hours before the meeting so
you're going to block off 30 minutes for
public hearing and so somebody who wants
to come and say something may not be
there at the onset but may show up five
minutes before that 30 minutes is done
so you really need to hold your meeting
till that full 30 minutes is has gone by
um
that's one thing the other thing is
there are School Board policies again
that give the Public Authority and
Direction on how to file their
complaints how they're addressed there's
a sequence and a chain of command who do
you see first who do you see next if
you're not satisfied you go here here
and here but it's done to keep Law and
Order
and civility
in how we're running these systems
that's it
representative Damon
thank you Mr boister I have two things
um
since you're the author of the amendment
I'm wondering if you would entertain
uh revision of the amendment to remove
the part of line seven and eight that
reads and shall also be provided for
non-agenda items of community interest
thank you
and then I have a second
separate question
um yeah maybe when we get the full
committee together we can talk about
that thank you uh your second comment is
I'm wondering I know we have people in
the audience from the New Hampshire
school boards Association I would love
the opportunity to hear from them
I think we heard from them during the
original meeting
um let's continue let's yes right can we
continue with the member comments
yes representative Woodcock thanks
Jennifer Ellie um I'd like to go back I
want to follow up on on what uh hope
said the the third time limit is issue
and I agree with Mike uh we have to sit
there and listen uh but we have to
listen to relevant comments and deal
with agenda items so I think that's the
difference like in this and that that if
it's not on the agenda if the agenda
item a public has the right to input I
like the fact that it's done before they
vote but but if it's not a general item
I don't think they should be getting a
free a free warrant like that I think it
just opens up to too much too much um
divisiveness uh in the school board yeah
School Board member I spent 20 years of
school board and I I'd still be sitting
in a meeting we had to open it up to
anybody want to talk about anything
um
since we're still waiting for
representative lad to return why don't
we take a break for 15 minutes and see
everybody needs an update of where we
are here
it would be nice huh the first hour down
in division two we dealt with two bills
one of those bills was Career Technical
education tuition and transportation
they bought it and they're going to put
it into the legislation that's moving
forward that would put another 2.2
million dollars in the Career Tech for
each year of the biennium so a total of
4.4 million dollars which is needed if
we're going to ever get more kids
involved with CTE programming including
the transportation so that was a very
successful one and then the other bill
which we dealt with was the weighted
formula for differentiated Aid special
education the buying into the formula
also
and and so so with those the time we
spent this morning for that hour down
there is showing and those bills came
out of this committee unanimously and so
they're listening to policy and they're
trying to you know adjust budgeting for
it uh the within the hb2 they already
had the differentiated amount of
2079.89 which is the amount for
differentiated Aid which would
automatically occur result of the CPI
and everything else
um that's there but they're also looking
now at the three categories awaited this
uh would go from two thousand dollars to
four thousand dollars to six thousand
dollars depending on whether category a
b or c c is the one where the remember
if they're in residential placement or
or a hospital placement or other
placements similar to that more costly b
as if you're in a situation where it's
um 80 percent or more that's uh needing
uh special services especially during
the course of a day so that's pretty
much almost full-time special education
that would be weighted at about four
thousand dollars and then if you're less
than eighty percent it would be weighted
at the same amount that's in the in the
bill right now so all they have to do is
modify that one component hb2 and I
think we've got that one so that was
good a good time down there
um
I know that you all I couldn't take any
action and move forward here but I think
that when we're looking at those
priorities that came out of this
committee
um it was an hour worth spending
um as soon as we have folks coming back
from that we'll move forward with trying
to exactly we will be taking a break at
noon time
um for lunch
so with that we still have uh
representative Miler and represent
Tanner are now they're down there
dealing with other bills and we the
other bills coming up down there today
are Medicaid Direct
which is a huge bill in terms of
eligibility
and I also noticed that down there today
we also had the staff member that's been
hired to take care of Senate Finance
Karen umberger was down there today
participating in um and so we had a
little opportunity to talk about the
whole budget that the governor's
presented and what we're after ourselves
so
um we'll have to wait and start our our
discussions unless I'm once you update
me a little bit uh Glenn where you were
or worked in terms of the bills for
executing today yes we uh passed over
um House Bill 204 the non-academic
surveys we were finished with discussion
on that at that point
267 we had a complete discussion on that
um the uh the next bill we we passed
over completely 371 and we were
approaching completion of the discussion
okay so we can't take any action the the
we agreed uh if somebody's out
testifying down there we would not move
forward with any executive sessions
and you can rest assured that we will be
down there for Medicaid Direct
and that will be another one where we
won't have any time so we got to really
if we can get any discussion done
further on these bills
um get somewhat an idea where people are
I think we ought to move that direction
right now
okay motions were put on the table for
all those other bills uh really just
discussions discussions okay
we did uh I guess we did have uh motions
well for the first one yeah right and
for the second one uh 427 I just
introduced my mention my my Amendment
and which one
427 yeah right okay so 451 we haven't
touched yet
okay let's talk about 451 now without
any kind of uh a motion being made is
there anybody that has
some information they want to impart on
it
are there any amendments on it
okay
Mr chair that that's um representative
Canada's yeah
okay so we'll jump over that one yeah I
see it's syrup Santana's Bill thank you
let's go to the next one down then 550
relative Charter Public School
dissolution
you got an amendment
which is uh
he if we're going to be getting into the
business of um at some point of looking
into providing State Building they need
what's that yeah yeah I didn't have that
going but uh let me get the let me send
yeah
I don't know if that's enough going that
way
foreign
I'll just sort of lay a little
groundwork so so so back in February
13th uh we held a hearing on houseboat
550 it was introduced by representative
fellows the um the the bill is
introduced
uh uh provided um
some uh
what happens to
assets during the dissolution of a um of
a chartered public school and uh
and um I I think following some uh some
conversations with representative
fellows and I think it may have happened
even during the hearing that uh that it
seemed to be
um good to um to eliminate the policy
part and just focus on establishing a um
a committee to study uh chartered school
dissolution and as I was just starting
to say the reason why this is important
is uh because the legislature may be
looking to consider down the road uh
expending uh State assets in terms of
building aid for uh for Charter Public
Schools and um and you know unlike
municipalities which don't really
um
well municipalities have a
constitutional obligation to provide
um education for all of the children
that live in that in that municipality
Charter Public Schools don't have any
constitutional obligation to provide uh
to provide anything and um and I'm not
being critical of of Charter Public
Schools but uh but over the over the the
25-ish years that we've had Charter
Public Schools we have had a handful of
um of failures that resulted in
dissolution and and subsequent
conversations uh particularly between
representative fellows and the
department
um
really resulted in um and yeah this week
we need to put some some policy behind
what what happens here so so
um so Sally fellows and I are bringing
for I'm bringing it Forward
um Amendment zero six two four h which
replaces the entire bill with a uh with
a study uh committee to uh to look into
what would happen in the event of a uh
of a charter failure what would happen
to those assets and um and I I think
it's one of the key items that uh that
we need to have policy in place on
um uh you know at such time when the uh
when the state may consider to move
forward with with expending its capital
okay
um
when you put this together
representative luno did you years ago we
had a charter that went defunct
and we
had a situation where it could have been
a private school I'm just can't quite
recall but people were chasing after
transcripts
uh graduation transcripts and trying to
locate those eventually it had to be
done through doe uh
but that's another issue that's when uh
any school goes defunct
then what happens you know for a student
that's four years later saying I'm going
to go off to college but I have to have
my transcripts sent and the school is no
longer in existence uh how does that
occur
uh that's it doesn't have to do with
what you're doing necessarily here but
it is an issue which we've had to deal
with and and and the um the amendment um
contemplates that on page two line six
and seven uh under the um the the duties
of the um the committee in Roman three
uh where line six and seven on page two
non-financial issues related to
dissolution including but not limited to
uh notification of closure placement of
students and retention of academic
records okay good yeah Diana and I
recall Mr chair you and I having a
conversation on that uh issue we've had
some very wild conversations on this
um because kids couldn't get the records
in time to make it to the next semester
um further discussion on on the
amendment that uh it's just been
mentioned
yes represent cordelli uh thank you I
think just yesterday we passed uh uh
legislation um related to uh uh revision
to the Charter oversight committee
um and uh couldn't uh these issues be uh
addressed by uh that uh group rather
than a new committee
so so let me let me take that um Mr
chair so I think the charter oversight
committee and and representative Tanner
I think uh could weigh in on this I
believe is more about oversight of of
current operations as opposed to study
of new policy
um this is this is particularly centered
on study of new policy uh which I I
think is beyond what the um what the uh
the oversight commission does and uh
and I think it's it's it's also relevant
to uh to point out in the amendment
down on the first page sort of between
some between lines 15 to uh uh to 21
where where it um uh yeah 15 or 21 where
it really talks about the type of
expertise and advice that the uh that
the committee would be able to Garner
um uh from um from people connected with
Finance from the uh the Departments um
um uh charter school officer from the
doj's charitable trust division
um
uh Das
um and uh and and of course and it's got
some you know standard language that we
put into a lot of committees you know
not limited to or other any other people
with relevant
um background and expertise so I I think
it probably goes beyond what the what
the oversight does
represent cascadden
question is there any reason why when
there's uh when when a school dissolves
that all the school records are just
returned to their owners
or is there something about having to
store them
well there's the issue the official
records too uh if if you're applying to
a college they don't want it coming from
the student they want it coming from the
issuing Institution
yeah the department we had a little less
session with the Department would be
retaining those records yes we did
that's the one I was trying to recall
yeah yeah that that is a a real issue
Mr chair yeah in colleges when they use
that too you're Mike
in college is when they do that
typically they find another college that
agrees to take the whole body of records
and they become the institution that
Services those needs for official
transcripts with seals and all that sort
of thing to go out for the acceptance to
other colleges whatever
yeah
so one of the things I notice and I'm
glad you took the first part out of this
because I had problems with the nearest
public school
District
charter schools of course receive kids
from various districts
and and the nearest
you know why why is that the nearest
response you know that that's online of
the original Bill line six and then
again on line 16.
yeah
and that and that's why we're not we're
not embracing the um the policy from the
bill is introduced it's that that would
really be
um something for the commission to the
from the committee for the study
committee to dive into and recommend
okay
um so we've been in discussion here
um where is yes represent Tanner I just
want to reiterate uh what representative
Uno said I don't think the legislative
oversight committee their job is to
really
um look at the functioning of schools
the approval of charter schools get to
get a report to them from the State
Board of Education and then issue a
report
um to the House and Senate education
committees it it doesn't deal with
the specifics of of this wouldn't this
wouldn't I don't think be in their
purview at all
okay so what I'd like to do because it's
the first time we're seeing this I'd
like to take a caucus for about five
minutes here and so I can talk with
folks about this and and find out where
we want to go
yeah
is it no it's not
okay
thank you
it's got the emotion made up by now okay
um so I think so let me go ahead okay
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to address a HP 550 and I'd like to
recognize
um
perhaps in Luna for a motion
thank you very much Mr chair I'd like to
move um about to pass on 550 and I'd
like to move ought to pass on Amendment
0624h as well
okay there's a motion on it is there a
second okay representing my our second
says so the basically the the motion
right now is to move on 550
and it's also been requests that we
attend to zero six two four h is that
your code correct thank you and that was
second by representative miler
representative luno
um thank you very much uh I really don't
have anything to add uh beyond what what
uh what was said early but earlier but
um uh the amendment uh zero six two four
h replaces the bill in its entirety with
uh with uh language to establish a study
committee to Charter to study chartered
Public School dissolution and
um
um and I hope people will uh we'll I
hope this committee will support the the
uh the amendment favorably as well as
the bill is amended
and uh representative Meyler do you have
any further discussion no any further
discussion from the committee not seeing
any uh Madam clerk would you please call
the roll on Amendment zero six four uh
Vice chairman cordelli
no
representative like us yes
representative Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative tensar yes representative
Myler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative priests yes
representative Balboni yes
representative calc cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
Ladd yes
19 years one day okay at this point I'm
going to hand the gamble over to
representative cardelli yes and I'd like
to call on chairman lad for a motion yes
I'd like to make the recommendation
ought to pass on 550 as amended by zero
any further discussion on the otpa
see none
motion is otpa vice chairman cordelli no
representative leckis yes representative
Ford
yes
representative Belcher no
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative tenzar yes representative
Myler yes representative Cornell
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative priest yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes 18 years two Nays any objections to
consent no
okay so we'll just go down to that does
anybody know what's going on down at
division two right now in terms of the
I think what we probably ought to do is
just break for lunch right now
and then come back at one o'clock and
get this stuff polished off
I I want to get down there and make sure
that our bill is not coming up
down division two
multiple bills yeah so we will take a
break right now and we'll come back at
one o'clock following lunch
it could be times for your perfect thank
you all thank you very much
foreign
we did have a motion on the floor on
that
yeah
okay we have a motion that's on the
floor on OTP and we were in discussion
on that
not saying the request from further
discussion uh Madam Kirk when you're
ready yeah well where's where where'd
and that three plus pay all you can eat
okay so we're ready to go ahead then so
we do have a motion on the table was was
OTP for HP 204
Is there further discussion
no I'm clear
motion is OTP Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald
yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative tensar yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Ellison no
representative Woodcock no
representative priests no representative
Balboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no and chairman
Ladd yes
scores 10 years 10 Nays
said a second on the itl motion
representative Tanner so motion made ICL
by representative Myler and second by
further discussion on the motion
not seeing any uh
Clark would you please call the roll
motion is itl vice chairman cordelli no
Representative lekas no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative try no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative tensar no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative priest yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
Ladd no
10 years and 10 Nays
is there any further discussion not
seeing any
so what we will do is we have uh no
recommendation on this
the uh you'll be writing who made the
Reps and Belcher
woodcock
yeah like uh four o'clock five o'clock
this afternoon yes sir
or later maybe because we may be here
hopefully not okay next one down is uh
267 relative criminal records checks and
school employment
and what was the status in that I don't
know if anything was put on the table
I think there was an OTP motion
um and had quite a bit of discussion on
it okay who made the OTP on that
no
um no no I did that for
um oh yeah criminal record checks yeah
so 267. sorry my bad yeah so yes and
better now what's that okay so we have a
motion for ought to pass on HB 267 was
there any discussion that came from the
makers the motion did we go through that
yeah we did and the second and all that
yep represent Tanner I think from the
discussion we also talked about
retaining this bill
it okay further further discussion on
that
um on the OTP for
267.
okay Madam clerk would you please call
roll okay the motion is OTP Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leckis yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative tenzar yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Ellison no
representative Woodcock representative
priests no representative Balboni no
Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
yes
represent Myler
I was like I would like to move to uh to
retain this spill further stuff and I'll
second that is there a second so we have
a motion to retain made by represent
Myler and second by representative luno
further discussion from the maker of the
motion no I think we've had enough
conversation here
thank you very much Mr chair so so there
um there was we did have I think
substantial
um uh good debate and discussion on 267
and um and and probably worth uh worth
reviewing the YouTube video and I know
but but
um I think if if if we're to summarize
at least you know my notes into three
points
um I think the um the super the sponsors
um and and in particular the
superintendent Goffstown
um uh Brian balke
um have um have I think made a
reasonable case that um that that there
should be something that provides an
opportunity for a um for only to get the
term right a more frequent or recurring
basis to
um to to perform criminal history
records checks and um and that um that I
think that we also had some discussion
that um that the language that's in the
bill right now with respect to
um uh having districts conduct these
these a more frequent recurring
um records checks on quote on any group
of employees maybe that could be worked
on a little bit so that we get a better
understanding and that's the second
point and then the third Point
um I'd like to lay out is that um both
Captain Muzzy and and Christine J uh
from the uh from criminal records at the
department of safety uh also talked
about how
language like this you can't just enact
it in law before for to make it ready
for implementation it has to get
um approved by the um the Federal Bureau
of Investigation and and that um and
that they um would be able to help us
maybe take a look at at similar language
that's been approved in other states and
um uh and and I think through through
retaining the bill we'd also be able to
develop
um you know Mutual Amendment language in
cooperation with the school
administration Association which I think
has indicated General support for um for
for changes in the policy uh but also
other advocacy groups too you know and
and certainly working with the FBI uh
and getting some language that um that
that we feel strongly is going to be
acceptable to them so those I think are
the the the reasons in my well I think
retaining would would make a lot of
sense right here representative woodcock
thank you chairman I would just like to
add to representative piece the other
part I thought was substantive with the
fact that we hadn't identified who would
be responsible for the payment of the
the fee for the school district that
they're asking for or the employee I
think somewhere in the retain the retain
that has to be addressed as well thank
you
Is there further discussion
representative cardelli thank you
um I think that this there was agreement
I think that this is an important area
um and needs to be addressed uh I think
that the bill before us
provides for
um work in collective bargaining it
prevents any uh individual from being
singled out
I think that we should move forward with
this I know that the FBI has to concur
with the language and I believe the
testimony was that um
something would have to be passed before
the FBI would actually do that review so
I think we need to go ahead and pass it
further discussion
represent luno thank you Mr chair and
and you know I I I I generally agree
with with what was said with regards to
the importance of the bill I just um uh
think pertaining it would would allow us
to um to to you know bring forward
rather than a no recommendation which I
don't think tells the the right story on
on 267 bring forward a a um a strong
recommendation from this committee based
on the testimony that that we heard
um including that from Captain luzzy and
um and also recognize the work that that
um that is is going to be done I think
in parallel with this through the um
through representative McGuire's um
um of criminal records check uh uh study
committee and uh we had a number of
bills on uh related in in this in this
school safety area last session
um I'm surprised this didn't come up
then but uh but I you know I think we've
got a really good opportunity uh because
we all recognize the importance of this
to um to to put something together and
bring something forward that the people
in New Hampshire can uh can you know see
that's important because we together
further discussion from the committee
represent cascadden just a comment we
had a great discussion on this if you
get a um a reason you know a way to to
watch it but
um this bill as it is is yet another
unfunded mandate so that means you're
you know somebody's got to come up with
the money in the district
so it's another unfunded mandate
is it unfunded if it says may require
and how are you going to be able to do
equal opportunity or follow Title IX if
it's a May how are you going to pick and
choose that we that was part of our
discussion
it's done by district and so a district
May appropriate the dollars in a budget
for that purpose as a whole
now if they choose not to do it then
everybody within the district is treated
equally
Melissa is a reason it should be done
your District hasn't budgeted funding
yeah
representative McDonald did you have a
question
no
are there any further discussion on this
one
thank you Mr chairman the motion is to
retain
Representative lekas no
representative Ford no
representative Belcher
no
representative dry I wrote yay
representative McDonald no
representative paternal no
Representative tensar no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes
representative Allison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative priest yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
11 Yates nine days
okay the motion passes we retain that
bill
by the way today is voting day in
Vermont
okay
next one down
um
I I hear you jumped over you said 371
and went to 427 right so let's go where
you've discussed before so let's look at
427 relative public comment inquiry in
inquiry during school board meetings
were was there anything put on the floor
no motion okay thank you
okay
okay representative cardelli you're
recognized thank you I would like to
move on to pass and offer Amendment zero
okay we have a motion made ought to pass
and uh with Amendment
what was the number on that
zero seven four one H and second by
represent cordelli you're recognize
um I think we had uh quite a bit of
discussion with this
um I think there was a lot of agreement
that there were problems with the
original Bill uh the amendment uh
provides for uh public input before
action is taken by the board uh it also
uh provides that the public may offer
comment on non-agend items and it
revises the current statute
that says public comment for at least 30
minutes in the amendment we say that
there are no speakers
for the entire 30 minutes they can end
it earlier and that
speakers should be allowed to speak for
further discussion
oh yes representative Woodcock and then
representative
thank you representative uh chairman uh
uh representative Cordell is correct
this his Amendment does make a great
stride to improve the bill
um however uh as I commented in the
discussion earlier on and I'll do it now
since the fishing on the floor the fact
that we opened it up to non-agendal
items of community interest is just open
a wide array of of topics and uh they
have no value or substance to the school
board it could be about anything Grant
the rate of anything I'm not suggesting
that maybe other forms in a community
for those topics but clearly not the
school board the fact that they have in
in the amendment that you can address
the topic before is voted I think that's
substantively excellent idea but opening
it wide the knowledge and items of
community interest I think it's a killer
on this and I'd be happy to support this
amendment without that line thank you
representative a representative
yeah yeah yeah thank you very much Mr
chair so
um so the the question question I've got
is with respect to
the
the amendment and it's more of a
procedural question if this amendment
were to pass
and the and a subsequent vote of ought
to pass is amended were to fail and
um and let's say the bill came out of
committee without recommendation
um
would the amendment have any greater
standing than any other amendment that
might be offered on the floor yes
all right so could you explain how that
well seeing it was approved by the
committee
and no other Amendment on the floor will
have been approved by anybody until
approved on the floor so we take all
amendments that have been approved in
committee first
okay as part of that report
that where we end up with that whether
it was yeah it'd have to be not to pass
okay and I think based on an earlier
bill that we did I did check with the
clerk and so the one recommendation
would be ought to pass is amended with
the approved Amendment right right and
so the so the amendment would be the
first thing taken up the same way it
would be with a with any other committee
yes okay yes okay yeah great thank you
you're welcome
I do believe that it's important to
allow the public to speak on other
things not on the agenda I think it's an
assumption that it will be totally
um extraneous to the school board and
not something that they're interested in
I also think that this amendment as
written
should we have another I'll say covid
but not necessarily coveted but some
thing that gets parents upset
this lays out
a method
in advance
that can be followed and be being
followed so that when things come up it
will help keep from getting those heated
arguments that we saw during covid
where parents were not allowed to speak
where parents were very concerned about
a particular topic which wasn't on the
agenda but which was very important to a
large number of parents and when they
couldn't speak that's when tempers rise
that's when people get upset if you let
them have their say after all it's three
minutes
and it's 30 minutes total it's not like
you're going to be there all day and not
get to your business it's 30 minutes
it's three minutes
we have people we have public hearings
here and we have people who come in some
of them are regulars who are not always
Jermaine to the bill or to well let's
see speaking about aliens and abduction
and various other things and we smile
and we let them talk and we say hey we
say time is up thank you for your
testimony right
and we don't say blah so I think
it's important I think it's very
important for the public to know that
they're being heard whether or not the
school board then agrees
with what they have to say or disagrees
at least they know they've had their say
and I think we will be much less likely
enacted if we ignite enact this whole
thing as it is the amendment
to have disruptive school board meetings
in the future if some other
thing whatever it is we can't foresee it
comes up like covid came up that gets
you know parents as a whole upset about
whatever this gives them a chance to
speak their mind and be done
thank you
further discussion represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and just to just add
on top of that a little bit I I want to
go on record saying that because the
Constitution places restrictions on
government and provides or outlines
rights of people I don't actually think
we as a body or School boards have any
Authority whatsoever to limit what
grievances uh people are allowed to
further discussion represent Balboni
um yes I have a just a a question about
um so it says no less than 30 minutes
but if more people want to speak then
would go beyond that 30 minutes anybody
who wanted to speak would have three
minutes I mean it doesn't really say
anything about control after you know it
says in terms of the time limits below
it does say reasonable controls there
but it doesn't really
um in terms of a time limit and it also
doesn't say anything about
um each person only get one three-minute
period or
it's a little fuzzy on that and it's
okay further discussion representative
uh Lucas
I think that's where you leave that
discretion to the school board if they
see a whole lot of people who are really
animated and want to give them a chance
they can say yes on the other hand they
can say we're not going to get to our
committee meeting let us schedule
another meeting for that particular
thing
we will need now need to do our business
meeting
and I have seen this done in my town
and we didn't get excited angry anything
the school board meetings ran very well
because they listened they heard and
they said let us schedule
a time when you can come and ask us
whatever and they did that they listened
and I think that's part of what's
important here so that would be the at
the discretion of the school board to
say
yes we're going to hear you tonight or
no we're going to wait and hear you in a
week and
representative Cornell Thank you I I
can't find anything in the bill but is
there anything about that the the
speaker
um should be a resident of or have
something to do with the particular
School District that they're speaking at
or could someone from North Conway come
down to Manchester and give their
opinion
thank you
my experience when I I chaired the
select board in my community and it's on
city council elsewhere is that the
policies which we established as a local
board be it select board or city council
and we may adopt Robert's Rules which we
did in this particular Community here in
New Hampshire
and Robert's Rules when you're having me
you don't necessarily have to have
within Roberts rules public comment it's
a decision made locally but if you have
public comment then your your policy
that you've established as a town would
govern you know what we're talking about
right here the amount of time you might
you know want to have a person speak to
if that's in your policies uh and
whether it's about the the way I used to
run the meetings is they had public
comment irregardless
of what was on the agenda I'm talking
about Municipal Affairs and things such
as that might be related to a zoning
board issue which they've had previously
and it's not on the select board agenda
I allowed them to speak
um I think it's the best way to deal
with the public to afford them the
opportunity to have that option not to
ever shut them down
I don't that answered your question or
not well no I I wasn't so much concerned
about what they were talking about as as
where they were coming from to talk
because I know one of the problems
during the shutdown was people were
traveling all over the state I can give
you another situation when Walmart was
moving into Woodsville
here in New Hampshire and I was chairing
the select where that time and of course
Woods was right on the river in Vermont
Wells Rivers right across and we had a
number of people from Wells River
wanting to come in and testify stand up
and speak in front of this packed
Auditorium about how it's going to cause
congestion on their roads they want
traffic lights put in by us I would not
allow the people from Vermont to speak I
told them submit your testimony in
writing uh so we took testimony only
from the residents of Woodsville
Haverhill
and those towns which surrounding in New
Hampshire we did not allow people out of
state to speak but there's nothing in
this bill that says the school board
would have the right to do that if
somebody introduces them to Local policy
they could do that if they want to do
that that's a local decision if it's a
local decision do we need this bill
laughs
could in each district do their own
policy and and do their own
so do we even need this then if each
student can do their own policy we're
just being called too so
we're going to be in a discussion mode
here because we're just starting 5 29.
um and then 601 following that so
um
this is a policy decision
um a local decision you know uh you
could say that yeah it's up to the local
board to decide you know how many
minutes we're going to give I do that
daily here when the you as a presenter
come in I allow you uh 10 15 minutes if
it's necessary but subsequent testifiers
may only get three minutes
is
where are we on this
yeah it's a one in five 29 are gonna be
coming up soon uh they're looking at 4
30 and 626 right now I think that'll be
fairly quick
um goes to the EFA guard rooms do we
have anybody going down for those I know
I I need to get get down there that's
what Mickey was he's here are there any
bills we can take up quickly and knock
off so we don't have to do them tomorrow
and resets the rest have they started
those bills yet they're on a 10-minute
recess right 10 minute recess
let's try to wait we've got about five
minutes let's try to Wade through this
okay so we're going to take a caucus
if it's like Fonzie they're going to go
this is like the craziest day in the lob
I know it is there's too many things
representative like us yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes there was a representative
tenzar yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Woodcock no representative Priest No
representative Balboni no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
right
[Music]
then we vote on the amendment the
amendment failed
so we still have the motion a lot to
pass on the table
so yeah Mr Mr chair if the um if the
ought to pass motion fails I I will
motion is ought to pass
yes
walk me through it with the itl passes
or fails what happens to the bills
there's no recommendation from this
group
okay that still goes to the house and it
still goes to the full house anyway go
foreign
I think I might direct this question to
representative cardelli and I'm
revisiting from the morning discussion
hold on we do have do we have a motion
on the table
yes we do yes
so so there's no discussion right now
I'm just trying to get procedure out so
so we have a motion itl uh who made the
motion no
if if the um if it goes ought to pass
to the um excuse me no recommendation to
the full house
um the uh Amendment could be brought as
a four Amendment
could it not
yes
motion is off to pass Vice chairman
cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble
yes representative pedernal yes
representative tenzar yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Ellison no
representative Woodcock no
representative priests no representative
cascadden
no
I think you skipped me you went to
oh that's what happened
I said Bill bony I got it
I'll get balbon yeah
[Music]
I'll wear you on that right now I have
nine I'm waiting for representative
Damon
no and rep chairman Ladd yes and I have
10 to 10. thank you
I'm sure I'll make a motion of itl
hang on Sir second I second it okay we
have a motion made by representative
luno for itl and second by
representative
okay luno and any further discussion
from the maker of the motion no I think
um just one second a second okay so any
foreign
motion is itl vice chairman cordelli
no
Representative leckis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
representative
Ted Tsar no kintar
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative priest yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
10 years 10 days any further motions
not see any
10-10 votes so it'll go to the pool
thank you
okay
do we have enough time to do 552 that's
the one we carrying over from yesterday
if we don't do it today we've got a
recounter
so we need to take care of it too okay
HP 552
what's the title
the traffic
yeah
[Music]
this okay the way we'll do this will
have a motion put on the table and then
we will have a discussion if there is
the amendment will come up in that
discussion
and not not be meant to go the bill so I
would
um
move ought to pass on hb552 and there is
I have an amendment zero seven nine
and
I would propose
ought to pass on that amendment is there
a second second four seconds left
made by electus second by ripson Ford
Roxanne lecture welcome to speak okay so
there was much discussion on the
original bill
I've written all over it
um
the discussion was
first off that we felt that the awards
should go to these schools that showed
Improvement as opposed to the school
district and if it was going to the
schools then they didn't need as much
money
and we could reduce the amount of 500
000 instead of a million since we keep
throwing around 1 million here and 2
million there and whatever and all of
those add up
so we reduced the total amount
appropriated
um
you know okay we reduce the amount to 25
000 going to the school well no more not
in excess of twenty five thousand it
continues to be the
doe which comes up with what the rules
are and who would qualify
if there's money left over that money
goes to the next year and if there are
more than 20 schools which would be more
than our total money
um then it would be taken in order of
most improvement improvement to lease so
this is not
how good the school is doing yay you're
95 percentile you get an award this is
you were at 25 percentile and now you're
at 32 percentile yay you made
improvements so it's Improvement so the
schools most likely
to get these awards are the ones who are
most likely to be the ones who are the
most in need at the moment
um
what was the other
you want to speak to lines four through
line six in the original boss
intervention for social struck oh yeah
originally
the money came from the revenue
stabilization Reserve account and that
was an issue when this was put in before
we are leaving we have not specified
where the money comes from we figured
that would be up to finance to see where
the money was available
and take it from wherever it was
available
um rather than us as a policy committing
telling Finance where to find the money
either ways or means or Finance to
decide where that money is to come from
let's reward the people who are out
there really working to to make a
difference
and that's you know that's that's the
point of this
let's let's give them something to show
for their hard work thank you thank you
rep sound forward you'll make her the
second do you have anything to say on it
oh no further thing represent Allison oh
thank you Mr chair uh
I I had to agree with my colleague to
the left that this money probably would
go to districts that are most in need
there's no no factual basis for for
saying that and I'm on record during our
discussions over the last six months or
even a year that I'll not be voting for
any Appropriations that are not targeted
to those school districts that are most
in need this has the potential of giving
twenty five thousand dollars to
Hopkinton and I don't want to pick on
Huffington but I am uh Hanover
Waterville Valley they don't need the 25
000 the 25 000 needs to go to Newport
needs to go to Manchester needs to go to
Franklin needs to go to Claremont so
I'll be voting against the amendment and
the bill
further discussion representative
I have I have two questions one is in
line six a designated standardized
mathematics
test
um what exactly
is that supposed to mean is that the
state
standardized test or is it what that
would be determined by the doe as to
which tests they use probably that is
what they would use but there may be
well be one that's better or that comes
up that's better and so that leaves it
and my second question is that now that
you've got it by school rather than
District of for example in a co-op
District like here starts with eight
schools if if one of the and they have
several elementary schools in a middle
school and a high school would it goes
twenty five thousand dollars to a small
elementary school if that elementary
school was the one that had the that's
why it says
um not to exceed twenty five thousand
dollars because if it's a very small
school it may be that that what the
award that they would get would be less
than the twenty five thousand dollars
if it was very small but it would go to
the school itself that showed the
Improvement not to the whole District so
it could be a like a pick and choose how
much money they get it isn't like rank
ordered for second third fourth and
it you know or just the 20 schools each
get 25 000 it's it's the idea is the 20
schools or 15 if only 15 qualify get 25
000 and then that money gets carried
over to the next year and again
um the schools get ranked but if more
than 20 manage to show whatever the the
um
whatever the quali whatever the
qualifications that are set forth are
you know must improve by x amount but it
said it's to take into consideration the
size of the school the population all of
that
in in making those those
criteria for what who deserves an award
and then those that qualify but if you
end up with 22 qualifying well we
haven't put enough money away for 22 so
we're going to take
the time the 20 that show the most
Improvement and the reason well I was
gonna go ahead
so I really
um
appreciate that you've moved it to
Improvement rather than you know just
total performance so that that that's a
big thing but
um I'm kind of
a little bit hesitant about the
unintended consequences like for uh New
London Elementary as part of two or
three elementary schools in the district
all of a sudden gets twenty five
thousand dollars
um you know what what that's going to
mean and and whether it's going to go
just to that elementary school and not
the other elementary schools just I I
see some unintended consequences with
that just I think there's a misread here
about how we're interpreting this it
says not to exceed 25 Grand
so it can be up to it could be an award
of five thousand dollars let's say to a
smart school or ten thousand and the
money that's not used in that first year
is used in subsequent years to hand out
to the schools which are showing growth
in those substant years
I unders I understand that concept my my
problem is that you you
the I guess and you're saying you're
leaving it up to the doe for all this
criteria but yeah uh so do you have a a
list of okay not only the improvements
but the Nook is it a mathematical
um equation about the size of the school
the amount of
um Improvement the you know the number
of pupils
I I'm I just think it's that's last
sentence there in the bill it's
describes yeah
I appreciate the improvement with the
amendment but overall
I don't prefer this whole concept I
think we should be proactive about
helping schools
improve their programming as opposed to
rewarding
however they got there with money that
they can use for anything it could be
for a leaky roof not for math but I'm
further discussion representative
Cornell
I'm not sure about the definition of
school in this is it a public and public
charter school or is this open to
religious schools and private schools or
any school that shows Improvement on
standardized tests or
is that in there somewhere
of
yeah the idea yes it had said school
districts and we changed it to just
schools because we wanted the individual
schools within the school district
and so it says schools but
um
but I was wondering who the doe would
actually I mean that also could be in
the doe rules that says public and
public charter
but this doesn't say that it's just that
school so it could be religious private
right well except that it also says
shall communicate with school districts
and shall adopt such administrative
arrangements as necessary to implement
this section so that still keeps the
idea that it's schools within school
districts
go ahead represent cordelli yes I
Department doesn't provide funds to uh
your Microsoft's not public schools at
this point so I don't see how that would
enter into this the only question would
be whether it includes Charter Schools
or not
yep
further discussion rep representative
dry
thank you Mr chairman
um where is this supposed to sit in the
rsas
actually in the beginning it does say
relative to making incentive grants for
school districts that improve to certain
assessment scores so you're already
looking at public schools
and it does not say where it's actually
going to
sit
that Petter now had her hand up a number
of times
I was just going to say I think this
this
um this bill
gives schools the opportunity to
innovate and to be creative at the local
level in order to decide how they want
to improve in order to
um achieve these
um
we're not calling them Awards but um
representative
yeah we we like to believe that
everybody always works at their 100
percent best all the time
but what reality tends to show is people
work to incentives whatever the
incentives are if you give them
disincentives they tend to not do if you
give them incentives they tend to do
more it's the nature of people so we're
going to
reward that extra going Beyond to try to
figure out what to get what to do and I
know you're going to hate that because
you think everybody always works a
hundred percent I know what schools it's
going to be yeah I I would just like to
say I don't think schools do things on
the basis of getting rewards I think all
schools try their hardest for their
students to do the best they possibly
can without thoughts of monetary rewards
in their minds so I I I don't think it
incentivizes them or disincent devices
represent miler
thank you Mr chair I think the issue
here we're talking about is
the term
really is not Improvement
the term really is growth
what is the growth of a particular
school as it relates to their test
scores Etc
that's just an aside
for the discussion but I'm not through
you thank you uh okay the other concern
I have here is that this again
is another incentivized program
that negates the issue of the funding of
schools in general
and
um I have a problem in supporting this
without the kind of commitment from
right now we're what 24 of State funding
the schools
um and to me this just again
uh begs the question
of what is the state commitment to
funding schools in the proper way and
this is just another incentivized
program that just can to continues to uh
to Advocate uh that and not really deal
with the the basic issue of funding of
schools in general
further discussion
not see any further discussion Madam
clerk would you please call the roll
it's an amendment right on the amendment
zero seven nine eight H this is an
amendment 2
hb552 okay
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative tenzar yes representative
Myler representative Cornell no
representative Tanner
you know Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Woodcock representative priests no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
okay that there's no recommendation on
that I'll have to pass you down uh now
we're back to the main bill as
introduced
we have a motion of ought to pass
which was made earlier
chairman cordelli yes
representative lecas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative tenzar yes representative
Myler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner
no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock no
representative Priest No representative
Balboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
yes 10 10 years 10 days so refer the
motion representative Myler
I moved to Ico please is there a second
no I moved to Ideal yeah yeah is there a
second to the Motions yes representative
amen okay motion made by represent Myler
uh itl and second by representative
Damon
further discussion from the make of the
motion none thank you
any further discussion from the
committee not seeing any Madam clerk
would you please call the roll
motion is itl Vice chairman cordelli no
representative Lucas no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
representative 10 natar no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative priest yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
10 years 10 days
are there any further emotions
not see any so it'll go to the floor
without recommendation
represent Allison the writing that okay
you were just informed
did he inform you that he's going to
okay and Reps and Lucas thank you
can we find out what's going on with 529
right now representative
I think they're waiting
okay
we would just simply
I think this draw to go quickly so I'd
like to be able to finish a couple more
of those bills today
um
Let's see we have
state board we have one two three four
to go still four well did we do 451
451 625 and 629
well we did uh 550 yep okay that's right
across that up okay so we have three
bills to go yeah we ought to try to wipe
them out you know
let's go down we'll go down here I was
going to 550 or
yeah six five twenty nine
or 620
629. no no no no no no no for that down
and then
get back here and get these other bills
so we got three bills left for this
afternoon which we're going to try to
get done
uh you look at the bills which got still
stacked up in front of us we need to get
these done I would suggest anybody's
writing um uh committee reports right
now try to get those done now uh so you
won't have to be doing it later on to
yeah we jumped over 371 yes I missed
371 451 625 and 629 yeah
yes
we'll make some animal copies of these
yep
five
sure yeah
um
so we're going to take up 625 first here
please
Isabel
um
that deals with relative to the
calculation of average daily membership
in attendance and average daily
membership in residence for school
districts
so 625
take a look at it and I'll call upon
represent cardelli for a motion
I'm taking this chair and I would move
is there a second
I'll second okay okay so we'd move on
here
okay uh does the nick of the most want
to speak to the bill uh just briefly um
I think that there were some concerns
expressed during the hearing especially
about
the elementary and middle school levels
possibly
and figuring out uh courses in those
grade levels
that I think that we could work on and
look for a solution and that was the
reason I moved to retain it
I have no discussion uh are there is
all right Madam clerk would you please
motions to retain Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative lecas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative tenzar yes representative
Myler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative luno is not yeah okay
can't see you representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative priest yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
Ladd yes 20 years thank you consent okay
thank you well excuse me excuse me yeah
that's right we're not going to do that
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear friend
happy birthday to you thank you
everybody
yeah okay
um going on to next bill 371
establishing a commission to evaluate
and recommend standards for public
that is I think representative Bill
okay
all right
let's have a little discussion first in
this one before we have a motion on the
floor uh let me explain some of where I
uh have a couple concerns
one of which
I think uh the maker of this bill ran
out of the alphabet when trying to
identify commission members here almost
got the Z
so that that would be what one one
question if you can read between the
lines a lot of people on that thing and
I understand the the the concern for for
the bill uh intent I mean the other
concern I do have is is I believe this
is a a critical issue that needs some
resolution but needs resolution now
uh and I
I'm anxious once we start getting the
the uh minimum Public School uh
standards for minimum Public School
approval
that in our in our table here in front
of us then we've got to start looking at
that and one way we can do that is doing
having the
legislative oversight for improvement
and assessment or ourselves doing it as
a subcommittee looking at this right now
inviting people in to work on this I'm
sure that with those minimum Public
School approval standards we're going to
be looking at that intently and to then
review those this whole committee can do
that and we can do it with bringing
organizations and agencies to help us do
that and we could do it immediately
rather than having to wait until this
thing's signed into law that's that's my
concern right there
so I'll let I'll let representative luno
who is the primary sponsor of this bill
uh speak to you know the discussion here
sure no thanks very much Mr chair and
the importance the the important piece
on in 371 is um is on page two after
after we get through the 26 letters of
the alphabet
um when it talks about what the
commission shall do and um and you know
and it begins with reviewing the minimum
standards then goes on to determining
whether the current minimum standards
provide and then it goes on to identify
um Trends and disparities uh in the
state across the state and student
performance and we certainly have a lot
of evidence that that that that exists
but but it actually charges the the uh
the commission with with specific duties
that that sure this committee could the
education committee could take that up
but we're not charged with taking that
up this would actually put into law that
this commission has the authority to um
to review and um and and uh determine
um uh whether the minimum standards
provide an opportunity for an adequate
education for all students
um
I think probably most of us
um recognize and I think representative
Miler probably want to speak to it a
little bit I hope
um that that the Department of Education
is currently undergo undergoing a
a re-drafting actually wholesale changes
to the minimum standards for public
schools and um and unfortunately it has
been done uh without
um much collaboration it has been done
uh out of view from members of the
public it's been done out of view from
from uh superintendents and teachers and
school administrators
and and this commission would seek to
change that by by having them become
contributing members to the group that
reviews and and determines whether
whether changes
oh our um you know are are actually you
know good for uh providing an adequate
education and and uh and addressing
disparities uh in student outcomes uh
across the state the um the the the the
department of Ed who's currently
embarking on um on on a a rewrite a
complete rewrite of the minimums of the
minimum standards for public schools is
doing so with a contractor
um again not very in not a very
transparent process but a couple of
other rules that they have
um Rewritten and proposed recently do
things like eliminate requirements for
superintendents
um and maybe Dr cascadden can speak to
this one but but uh I think it would
only require a superintendent to have a
little bit of teaching experience and
not much else there's also a proposed
rule that I think is before the State
Board of Education soon they just had a
hearing on it last month that would
eliminate uh requirements or
qualifications for school business
officers so the school business officer
in Hopkinton might the town I live in
um has 24 million dollars go go through
her hands uh every year and it would
eliminate the the requirements for
school business officers so to be honest
Mr chair the track record
the commissioner's track record in terms
of eliminating requirements I think
should should really cause people across
the state to
um uh some you know pretty strong degree
of concern and um and you know
superintendent so that's District
Leadership School business officers
that's um that's that's Financial
integrity and fiduciary responsibilities
and
um and what this bill talks about is
obviously the minimum standards for uh
for schools so that's our that's our
I'm I'm I I wholeheartedly support what
the chair suggests that that that this
committee get involved in it but at the
same time
having having a statute that says that
it is the responsibility of this
commission to do it and there's no rush
to do it we don't need to run you know
full speed into a brick wall when it
comes to the uh the minimum standards we
have time to for this bill to go through
the legislative process to be signed
into law by the governor in June for the
commission to be named over the summer
and for it to start meeting in the fall
and um uh and I think the timing of that
would be um would be really good
considering that may be similar to the
timing when when when the the uh the
Department's contractor begins to um uh
disseminate the um the draft changes of
the rules this committee was promised
that we were going to receive
the Draft rules by Friday oh you'll have
them on Friday I'm I I think we all
thought that he was talking about fat
Friday of that week I had no reason to
believe that he wasn't speaking of that
but today we still haven't received them
um
so I for all of those reasons
um I I think um this commission is real
important
uh representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair I think it's a good
idea to work through this as you
mentioned and representative luno did
because it was created without a teacher
as the representative
and who best is in the field is a
classroom teacher
it also has some very radical changes in
it and I'm not opposed to changes and if
these are the changes
it's gonna it's going to affect a lot
more than just saying here's the minimum
standards because for school approval
you need to implement the minimum
standards and this and the
recommendations that I have and the
concerns that have been brought up by
school administrators because that's
where I got my information is that the
transition is going from eliminating
grades to learning levels and the
question is well what's a learning level
eliminating courses and going to a
learning opportunity what's a learning
opportunity it removes all of the
College and Career Readiness work that
have been implemented in the last say 10
years
so it is radical it also adds education
that is meeting the emotional health
needs of students
how do you how are you going to know if
you're meeting their needs on an
emotional level if it's in the minimum
standards and you don't have a the
Personnel to
deal with that
or
you have to question somehow to find out
who does need those needs
um so there's some radical things here
you know there are some good things in
it because yes
things have to change we're in a
different world and we want more
opportunities for kids not less
but remember the school funding is based
on minimum adequate education not an
average
not a maximum
so that's where you have the disparity
but it needs some work and it needs
people at the table
to make that transition and there needs
to be a
flow chart of transition in a time
period
thank you representative Lauer did you
have your hand up yes
thank you Mr chair
every 10 years
these minimum standards are reviewed
and as both representative cascaden and
Malinois said these standards are
critical
because they basically provide a
foundation
for what's going to be taught in schools
this uh current review was started two
years ago
it was contracted to a private outside
group
I have talked with the the director of
that program
they have been working on it for the
past 24 months and are now beginning to
share what they have come up with uh
representative cascadden has mentioned
some of the inputs there The Dilemma
that I think has taken place here that
there has been developed
within a certain cloud of secrecy and
that's what's caused a lot of angst
within the school Community about what
really is going on and it is just now
that it's beginning to emerge to try to
include people
to get input from them I know that
they've had a chance to meet with the
ascd which is the association of
it's a curriculum directors it's it's
the folks who basically deal with
curriculum out in the field they've met
with them and for a couple days have
gotten input from them the the dilemma
though is that there has been
unfortunately there is suspicion
um with uh I hate to say this but to be
very blunt with the commissioner
the Commissioners appeared before this
committee once in the last two or three
years
because he had a proposal for changing
curriculum those of us that were on the
committee last year will remember that
that time he came in and gave us his
view of what the standard should be
which caused severe concerns for some of
us on his theory about whether it should
be that I think has somewhat clouded the
perspective of looking at the current
current standards what this proposal is
trying to do is to create some
legislative oversight
regarding standards Etc and I think one
of the things that I know chairman Ladd
and I have talked about this is that how
do you how do you provide an opportunity
for transparency when you're beginning
to look at new new new programs so
there's no question in my mind that the
standards have to be revised they were
done 10 years ago we need a revised
there's no question about that but the
question is is how is it done how do you
how do you engage the school Community
that's basically out there on a
day-to-day basis seeing these changes
and what students are bringing to the
classroom there's no question in my mind
that students are bringing to school
today a much higher level of how they
get information I remember talking to
one student
and uh he was he pulled out his phone
and he says well this is where I get my
information Mr Milan and he said I said
what do you mean he says well ask me a
question now this this happened to me 10
years ago right so I I forget what the
question was and he goes like this and
he says is this the answer I said yeah
that is the answer he said now this is
the problem I have I know where to get
the information what I need schools to
tell me about how do I deal with this
information that's what I go to school
for
so as we begin to look at those kinds of
transitions of of opportunities for what
students bring to the school right now
and what teachers have to deal with from
a technology standpoint of availability
of information how do we deal with those
standards and I think what we're trying
to do here in this particular proposal
is to provide some some oversight and
some transparency of how we begin to
look at these things in a much more
Global passion rather than having five
or six people sitting over here in a
Kabbalah excuse me it's my editorial but
as as a trying to develop this without
engaging other people in the community
until after
the thing is uh kind of been set in
stone so my hope is that that this kind
of a commission would provide a much
greater transparent on an ongoing basis
not just necessarily on a 10-year basis
thank you Mr chair
uh I'd like to just make a couple
comments here that
first of all the legislation that came
before the house in the previous year
that representative just spoke to was
brought forward by Representatives
I was one of them
so it wasn't the commissioner bringing
it forward to this table as myself and
recognizing that there were certain
things we wanted to do with the adequacy
of which the end result was that's how
we got uh financial literacy
built into the adequacy formula the
second part I want to mention too is
that you recall last year we did
reinstate the legislative oversight
committee
and the legislative oversight committee
does have specific statutory authority
to be doing this it says right here
review and make recommendations related
to academic standards under
consideration by the State Board of
Education pursuant to RSA 19382
the legislature has given to the State
Board of Education the responsibility
they have been given that responsibility
for developing the academic standards
and the minimum School approval
standards that's been given directly to
the State Board not to the legislature
to do that
but we have the oversight
responsibilities
and this is why I'm trying to say that
that we need to do our job the
legislative oversight committee which is
part of this members in this body right
here are on it and the house we in the
Senate we have that responsibility and
we have the statutory authority to do it
so I don't see the need to accomplish
what is trying to be accomplished in the
bill that's before us is the only way of
doing that in fact we have a process
um now what we want to do is shift gears
and go to another process which I think
that's just totally a counter to what we
did by bringing and reinstating this
legislative oversight committee that uh
had been
deleted from statute back several years
ago when we were looking at all the
different committees that hadn't worked
for a while and yes that one hadn't
worked since we had identified the
education of Essa and and uh and when we
changed our our Statewide assessment it
was active then but we haven't made some
changes since then so it was two years
then people say oh there's no more need
for this well yeah there is a need
because every 10 years as represented my
own mentioned we have the task with the
response but for looking at adequacy and
that's what we're doing through that
bill when we looked at adequacy we
looked at it and modified it and we got
things such as logic and rhetoric built
in we've got the the we looked at the
indicators of that whole process so but
now the next step is let's look at this
minimum Public School approval standards
and when they are issued by the state
board when they issue are the Department
issues that that's when we have the
responsibility we have the
responsibility to take them and look at
them and do as we've been told we have
to do in legislation review and make
recommendations on that so for them to
go forward they have to have our
recommendations
so I think there's a process I think
that's the process we should follow
representative Cornell
the legislative oversight committee we
met on Tuesday January 10th and we were
told on that date that was a Tuesday
that on Friday we would have an updated
copy of the 306
recommendations
I haven't seen them no they haven't been
provided to us yet that's right but that
doesn't mean the legislative oversight
committee is you know they're ignoring
us we've had between now and then a lot
of bills which we have been addressing
uh it's just like we have to get the
public school infrastructure commission
going too that will start up after March
16th the the legislative oversight
Improvement assessment committee that of
oversight that I just mentioned either
written down to get that scheduled for
right after March 16th here well we have
a copy of the 306 recommendation that's
going to have to come from the state
board I can't guarantee anything because
we've asked but those are going to
eventually have to come out and when
they do come out that's what our that's
when our job will begin because they did
tell us on January 10th that we would
have them by that Friday
I can recall that yeah that so I'm not
negating that I'm just saying that uh
that's all the more reason why we want
to be looking at that but we have all
these responsibilities the oversight
committee has we've listed them from
from a to l
that we have responsibilities to do we
need to follow those responsibilities
and the process has been set up I don't
see the need for going for 371.
represent Tanner thank you I have a
question about the legislate legislative
oversight committee
um is that an oversight Committee in
general for everything or is it
specifically for the minimum standards
because my thought is
that
this commission is specifically for the
minimum standards and it what I like
about it
very much is that it that it does have
almost all the letters except Z
on being inclusive
um and you know back in the dinosaur age
when I first came to New Hampshire to
teach
I started teaching in an open concept
school which was
uh very state of the art at the time
um there were only seven schools in New
Hampshire that were open concept at the
time Charlie Marsden was the
commissioner of education at the time
and I remember spending the whole year
before we actually went into the school
to develop curriculum to develop
procedures the state department came uh
on a once a week to meet with the
faculty that was going to go to that
particular high school
so that when the first day came
everybody was pretty much ready and
pretty pretty much going and we talked
about the community response to that I
mean it was such a a large inclusive
deal this one sounds like all of a
sudden they're going to unveil the
the minimum standards dump them on the
table and I don't know if your
legislative committee has other things
to look at and be oversight uh besides
this but it doesn't have
the you know the different members the
representative of terrible uh unit
doesn't have a school nurse it doesn't
have teachers and the State Board of
Education is set up so that there's no
one within with current educational
UH responsibilities so it's like um
I just feel as though the commission
would be great and it would soften the
the
um
the load of this whole thing on
particularly on teachers and on schools
further discussion from the committee
yes represent Damon
very simple what is the RSA for the
legislative oversight committee that
you're representing 193-c colon 8
Dash a legislative oversight committee
Statewide education Improvement and
Assessment program thank you we when we
identified with the new math standards
those math standards were approved by
the Legislative oversight committee
they could not use those Mass standards
until that committee had approved them
so the the committee has been used
before in this regard
now I don't know why we want to diverge
and move off course yes we that
committee can pull in as many people as
many organizations that are required to
review
can hold hearings can do the whole nine
yards and it can start right off as soon
as those standards are approved if
you're going to wait for this bill to
get it's going to be
um what the effective date is
um this section is shall take effect
November 1 no
2027. yeah I think it's um some problem
with the effective date so we're talking
um
you know it's
so I it's you know
personally if you want to have ability
to do something and recommend on them
the quickest way and the statutory way
to do it is with the oversight committee
which we and represent literal you and I
represent Damon
so two things and please correct me if
I'm wrong
um
the date on HB 371 of 2027 is only for
the repeal
of number two the actual first report is
November 1st 2025. it's much sooner
preliminary for June 1st 2024. uh
separately from that just in
a quick looking at the legislative
oversight committee the membership of
that is completely different from the
membership proposed here and in my mind
it is much less comprehensive
but strictly
legislators there there's no
specification of there being people of
any
educational discipline at all
no disrespect to all of us legislators
but
well in response to that we've had these
committees before and we pull in all
kinds of people to testify and assist
and participate uh they don't all have
to be listed we have brought them in I
can remember numerous committees which
we've had on curricular areas we brought
in the Specialists be it the the
people sitting right there person
sitting there right now from the school
board say then active participants in
the past we've had various organizations
come in that are in support of reading
or mathematics come in and speak to
where we are where we need to go uh so
this doesn't eliminate you from using
it's it's it's the vehicle that the
state has set up to do what you're
asking do by way of this way right here
unless you're willing to put together
all this all the staff here and have all
these people voting or something pulling
them in it's going to be a huge huge
task when it can be done efficiently
with what we have in the books right now
Representative cordelli no thank you uh
yes even with
um study committees over the summer
we've pulled in many different groups
many different people so
um that that is common in uh is um part
of the process
um and I I see the duplication between
this and the oversight Committee just in
lines 27 and 28 with the recommendations
um parallel what's in uh statute now for
the oversight uh committee
um so I I think I agree with the
chairman in that
um you know if we really want to take a
look at the minimum standards
um
we have in place already the vehicle to
do that
represent cascadden just repeat that
apital C
colon 8.
the page number oh she's skipping the
represent Allison your hand up yes
please uh I I think it's related to the
bill not necessarily the substance but
I'm what I'm wondering and this is
anyone's guess but I'd like to hear some
guesses I wonder where you're going to
see the draft of the standards are we
talking about another month we're
talking about three months we're talking
about September or we were hey and are
there any assurances from anybody that
there's a date out in the future where
they will be available
okay
is
yes
uh thank you Mr chair yeah and it does
say specifically that we don't have the
responsibility in law to develop these
it's that of the State Board of
Education both minimum standards and the
minimum Public School approval standards
but we have the task then to review and
recommend these
okay not seeing any further discussions
we need to get on to the beyond the
discussion stage here yes just just just
quickly
um to to in in comparing the oversight
committee with what 371 is looking to
create 371 is very specific with respect
to the minimum
um the minimum standards for public
school approval the commission shall
recommend model minimum standards for
public school approval recommend to the
State Board of Education rules for
fulfilling the minimum standards for
public school approval I'm not seeing
the parallel in the legislative
oversight committee on page 541 so the
198 c8a oh sorry 193 c8a
um Provisions because what what what the
is charged with really revolves around
198 H which is the accountability
provisions
and not the minimum standards for public
school approval
so I I see these as two very separate
and distinct
um
committees
further discussion
okay we're gonna we're getting now into
the mode of uh printing a motion on the
table here so
um
yeah
this is uh House Bill 371 and I call on
the chairman for a motion yes I I move
you're a second
representative Ford
uh further well the the comments I have
are I think I've already made them in
the discussion and it's getting late in
the afternoon but uh the the the task I
believe
how this is going to be accomplished and
how it should be done is that that's
outlaid outlined in the statutes already
and this provides us the opportunity to
get on it immediately
and I think that's what the state would
ask us to do
uh and so I would prefer to
accomplish the tasks which you see that
outline in 371 through the statutory
methodology that's already put in place
for us to follow
for you I make that pretty well covers
it thank you great thank you
um any further comment well can we get
on with the vote great thank you madam
Clerk
the motion is itl Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald
yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative
tensar yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell now representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock no
representative Priest No representative
Balboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon and chairman Ladd
yes
I'll move uh hard to pass
is there a second second
so with motion on the table itl on uh
371 made by Representative
no oh OTB excuse me
further discussion
Madam Clerk
just a moment
okay the motion is
OTP Vice chairman cordelli
no
Representative leckis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative try no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative tensar no representative
Myler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative priest yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
are there any further motions
not see any there is no recommendation
made I'll write the itl motion and
representative Luna I'm assuming you'll
write
okay
um
a couple bills here and one word and see
451 is a bill relative to the State
Board of Education prohibition on
discrimination
okay
represent Cardell you recognize for a
motion uh thank you Mr chairman uh I
would move uh itl on the house bill 451.
is there a second represent Belcher
seconds the motion represent cordelli
would speak to your motion uh thank you
um I think we're getting into uh
territory
um beyond our responsibilities
um I I see many uh issues with this bill
um educational vendors who are they
there is
um indications that any child in an
approved home education program
um uh might have this applied to them
there are claims
to be submitted to the Department of
Education for discrimination purposes
which is
um
totally uh new um and I don't think in
line with the responsibilities of the
Department of Education uh so I think
that this is a uh a reach um you know no
one wants to see discrimination but uh
this is getting into territory that we
shouldn't be in I believe
uh further from the maker of the second
a second the motion represent Belcher
ditto
okay further discussion representative
Tanner
thank you um I'm the prime sponsor of
the bill and this uh isn't the first
time I've had this bill it's a very
simple bill there's two levels of
non-discrimination laws that affect
education affect New Hampshire one is
the the federal laws uh offered by Title
IX and a few other areas basically uh
they're very basic race religion
ethnicity
um New Hampshire and its wisdom has
expanded protected classes on their
non-discrimination bills um to uh
physical mental disabilities gender
identity sexual orientation religious
Creed you can read it in lines
five through ten and our Public Schools
abide by that and our Public Schools
public charter schools are supposed to
abide by as well
um I've heard
anecdotally that some people have been
uh having the vouchers and going to
schools and
um have been told they're not a good fit
and they belong to the some of these
protected classes I don't think that's
um what New Hampshire would the people
of New Hampshire would want and
certainly I don't think that
discrimination is fair
um I think that as far as educational
vendors is concerned that we we've had
this discussion before there are certain
vendors that are approved by not only
the scholarship organization but also
the doe certainly
um
that that is not a big issue and there
is a bill um
I don't know if it's being heard today
or tomorrow uh in which the doe is
actually
asking to be able to receive
discrimination complaints so
um I think that issue is uh that was
brought up that the doe isn't set up to
to uh
take uh discrimination complaints and
certainly in this bill it says that the
Discrimination complaints can go to the
Department of Education or the New
Hampshire Commission on human rights and
the New Hampshire Commission on human
rights has traditionally been for
employment and housing and in employment
and housing in the state of New
Hampshire all these protected classes
are protected
um and recently it's been extended into
some educational discrimination cases so
they're they're getting
um the last time we had this bill there
was some discussion whether they were
set up to handle education
discrimination cases than they are I
just think it's fair I mean I think we
have a responsibility
to give a free adequate education to
every child
all children regardless of where they
come from their parents their economic
status
that's what our com that's what my tax
payer funded resource funded money
should go for that's what I wanted to go
for I think that's what the majority of
citizens of New Hampshire think their
money is going for and
um so I think that with
that type of taxpayer resourced money
goes accountability and this is just one
part of the accountability for it so
um I offer this legislation cordelli
uh thank you uh two things um first uh
the bill related to um complaints uh
being sent to the Department of
Education was my bill
and the issue there was uh in large part
uh complaints being forward to the
Department of Education by
administrators in schools about things
that were going on
the problem that they ran into was the
inability to make referrals to the
Attorney General's office because it
wasn't in statute
the Attorney General's office denied
um receiving those complaints from the
Department of Education based on the
legislation that has been worked out the
Attorney General's office is now in
agreement and they're drawing up
language so the Attorney General's
office will receive those complaints to
take to the Human Rights Commission
that's point one in terms of private
schools and discrimination
um
private schools do not have the taxpayer
funding that public schools have they
cannot accommodate some children with
disabilities they work to make sure that
they are not accepting tuition money
just to get tuition money and not being
able to provide the adequate services to
those children with disabilities
um
they will tell those families we cannot
provide the appropriate services for
your child I've got documentation about
from the
Catholic Church about their
inclusion policies for children with
disabilities and trying to work with
children with disabilities to the best
of their ability
I uh I wonder with discrimination in
private schools would we require a
Christian School
to accept a teacher applying who
believed counter to the faith and be an
instructor in that school would that be
required as part of this bill Point
number two and point number three I
don't know if the State Board of
Education wants to get involved with uh
hearing discrimination cases
I think that they probably have enough
work on their hands
further discussion represent Tanner
I'd just like to respond to that first
of all you'll notice that this bill is
about admissions
um how the employment again is through
the Human Rights Commission and there
are specific rules regarding religious
schools and their employers there's been
a plethora of
legal precedences set for that so this
doesn't even talk to that this is about
students and
I would say that um one of the things
that bothered me the most I think was
that
let's say a student has been going in a
public school for a number of years and
has a disability and that school and
part of the part of the issue with
school funding with funding public
schools and why private schools and
um voucher schools are that much cheaper
is the fact that public schools if they
have somebody with a disability has to
have a ramp has to have some way for
that child
regardless of what disability they have
to be included in the school we have an
inclusion policy where it's the least
restrictive environment and
so here's a student that's been in a
public school and then the parents
decide that they would like to and
perhaps the it's the end of sixth grade
and the parents decide that there's no
Junior High School that they're out that
the kids are all going to a different
school and there's a really nice School
nearby maybe a Kua or you know a Cole
Brown and most of the school kids get
into that but this kid with disabilities
because she's in a wheelchair or because
he has a learning disability that needs
special accommodations
can't follow their can't with the efas
can't follow that into a school I think
that's when you think of it as that or
the fact that that the kid is um turned
away because they're not a good fit
because perhaps their parents are
um you know lgbtq
um that to me is not what I want my
taxpayer money going for that's not what
the public good is that's not what
um is right in my mind so
um
represent McDonald's thank you Mr chair
it has been mentioned a number of times
that a student might be told they're not
a good fit for a program because they
are a member of one of these protected
classes
but that appears to be an implied
causation how are we
do we have reason as a committee to
believe that it is because they are a
part of one of these groups as you
mentioned a parent could be lgbtq wizard
testimony presented that I am not
recalling that says that it is because
they were one of those or could there be
another reason the institution may have
for finding someone may not be a good
yes represent pelcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to draw
some attention to one particular part
that I find a bit curious because most
of this proposed Bill the language seeks
to expand protected categories but
there's one small area that seeks it
seems to actually limit protected
categories and that's where we see the
word creed creed is pre-existing law
that is protected already but in this
bill it adds the word religious Creed
so it adds the word religious before
Creed thereby limiting the scope of
creed so I'm wondering if that right
there
because Creed obviously you could
interpret that to mean ideological Creed
you could interpret that to mean
political Creed so I'm wondering if that
right there is something that could lead
to a political or ideological
discrimination because it's not outside
further representative cardelli thank
you I just note that the um the first
states that implemented
um programs for Education savings
accounts the primary eligibility student
population was children with special
needs in all of those first Six States
those states have grown
parents are finding that they are not
getting the services that they think
their child needs in the public school
and are looking to get their child those
Services elsewhere
the success of those States in providing
education savings accounts to those
families is proof of that
further discussion representative just a
clarification on the word creed it's a
statement of a basic belief of a
religious fate
Faith a system of Christian and other
yes representative
I'm I'm still confused as to how an
online program or an educational vendor
can be discriminatory in Admissions and
looking for an answer
me
Mr chair
yes representative I think Crete is in
the original statute it's it's in 300
something so we don't have it in our our
books
um but I I um as far as the online
vendors
um again it's admissions so if
um say prenda or uh velax has uh courses
um and I'm sure they they don't do this
but that they
a vendor like that might discriminate
and say this person wasn't wasn't
eligible for taking that particular
course all up yes what happens if they
turn out to be discriminatory
well that's I mean the this bill uh it's
anything
um you know like if you feel you're
discriminated against and even though we
didn't have anyone specifically come
into the to the
um testify on that there certainly is
anecdotal evidence out there
um if you feel you're discriminated
against then uh you have someone that
you go and Lodge a discrimination
complaint with and in this case you know
this school superintendent or just like
a Title IX complaint you have a person
that that's designated within the school
to handle those complaints then it goes
to the Human Rights Commission usually
and they do an investigation to see if
that's actually the cause and then tries
to make
um some discriminate you know some sort
of resolution to it if there isn't a
resolution to it they feel a law has
been violated then they turn it over to
the AG's office and that's how they get
involved that's that's how generally
discriminating patient cases are handled
can I just ask one more yes go ahead so
the question my question is
and and then if that happens does the
money not get spent the written office
not being eligible to receive any money
anymore or like what happens to somebody
if they are ruled on as they've been
discriminatory
that that depends on what the
judicial area decreased for them to
change either they have to change their
practices or you know I mean certainly I
didn't put in here that they have a
civil right of action which occurs in a
lot of
um bills that we get but I'm sure that
if they that that would be one
um Avenue that they could take would be
as civil rights of of action against
um the person or
organization that's discriminating
against them just it's like
anything in the in the state I mean now
we have housing and we have employment
um that's generally covered by uh the
Human Rights Commission and they've
they've had a number of you know they
get constant uh complaints so
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair just to clarify what
I said before yes the word creed is in
the original existing law but the word
religious has been proposed to be added
before the word creed and from the
Oxford language dictionary the second
definition under the word creed a set of
beliefs or aims which guide someone's
actions so religious is not the only
type of creed and you could interpret
this very readily as allowing for
political or ideological discrimination
that does not that does not fall under
religion because it adds the word
religion before creda
further discussion
the thing that I have an issue with is
mental handicaps and my question is
if you have a school that is
specifically designed or it could be
physical handicaps if you have a school
that is specifically designed to take
certain students and that's the focus of
the school whether it's
somebody who's gifted or somebody who's
dyslexic or somebody who's Down syndrome
and somebody who doesn't fit into that
category
wants to attend that school it wouldn't
be a good fit for them
and are we going to now claim that they
are being discriminated against because
whatever they don't fit into that school
that's designed to deal with a specific
need
I'll answer them so you'll see in this
in paragraph B where it talks about
schools that are set up expressly for
the same sex
single sex or to classes or programs or
activities in an educational institution
that are offered to students of a single
sex or who are separated by sex so that
covers like all boys schools all girls
schools Girl Scouts Boy Scouts whatever
what you're talking about is
um non-protected classes can they be
non-protected classes discriminated
against these are the people that are
listed here these are the categories of
protected classes they're there because
they have had a history of
discrimination and therefore have
received protected status from the
government and from the New Hampshire
government and so it pertains to these
people applying to a public something
that has tax for taxpayer resourced
funds public funds
um that they should have admissions that
does not discriminate against these
people
now if it
fitted in the child isn't gifted
that's not
that's the the gift it is in a
discriminated class but somebody who is
maybe they have
whatever
you just can't it you can't use gender
identity sexual orientation religious
Creed color marital status physical or
mental disability national origin
ergonomic status
that those are the ones the physical or
mental disability that's what I'm
talking about if their mental disability
gifted as a mental disability no if the
school is designed for a gifted program
yeah and somebody with a mental
disability that will preclude them from
doing it all well in a gifted program
they are a protected class can they say
discrimination because they don't get
into the gifted school if they're
treated any differently than anybody
else in other words in order to get into
a gifted school I would assume that you
have to demonstrate that you're gifted
through a test or whatever and if they
can perform on that test regardless of
whether they're in a wheelchair or not
they should be allowed to be in that
gifted program if they have
um brain injury that
precludes them from being or some sort
of
genetic
problem that keeps them from having the
ability to pass that test that's not
being discriminated against because of
their disability it's be it's they're
not getting in because they don't do the
tests they can't achieve the gifted
status
cordelli
thank you I believe there's a school in
uh Rochester that um caters to uh
students with dyslexia the uh what was
the name of Ori uh um Gillingham yeah
um uh program and uh so if
someone without uh the uh dyslexia issue
comes to them and is denied uh admission
is that discrimination
we're talking about protected classes
that have that are discriminated against
because of how they look
what they you know their ability or
disability that their sexual orientation
that's what we're talking about we're
not talking about
schools that are for dyslexic and
somebody who doesn't have dyslexia can't
get in
if that if somebody has dyslexia and is
in a wheelchair and is denied access to
that school because that school does not
have handicap accessibility and doesn't
want to give them
have them come then yes but if they
applied to the school and there's no
demonstrated dyslexia and that's what
they do
further discussion
I mean we have no more discussion
wonderful
okay I will do that later then
I just had an attorney want me to
respond to something here not on this
bill
okay so uh not seeing any more
discussion on this bill we do have a
motion on the floor the motion is to itl
the bill
we're talking about this bill the right
the bottom here or it's HB 451 relative
to the State Board of Education
prohibition on discrimination no further
discussion with uh Madam clerk you
please call the roll
motion is itl vice chairman cordelli yes
representative like us yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative try yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative Tech tensar
yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Ellison oh representative
Woodcock nope representative Priest No
representative Balboni no Representative
cascadden no representative Damon no no
no no chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 days
where the motion represent Tanner uh yes
I'd like to make a motion off to pass
please is there a second okay
Madam clerk we have the motion made by
representative Tanner
OTP and second by representative Myler
representative care to speak to your
motion
I think I've done enough okay
how about you representative
ditto good any further discussion
when you're ready Madam Clerk
all right motion is ought to pass Vice
chairman cardelli no Representative
leckis no representative Ford no
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
no representative
tens are no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock absolutely
representative priest yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes please uh
chairman Ladd no uh
I'm assuming that represent Tanner
you'll do the report I will thank you
represent cordelli okay
uh that leaves one bill we can carry
this bill forward to tomorrow because
we're right on five o'clock and you want
to do it no
I'm game for it I'm going to get home
and attack anyways it's it's do we have
okay so with that we're going to carry
killer tomorrow at 6 29.
if you can look at the docket for
tomorrow we have some heavy lifting
tomorrow as well uh so uh it will be a a
busy
yeah and there will be a a republican
is
thank you for coming okay okay
okay yeah and anybody that has uh
reports due today please get them first
if you're uh working with representative
Myler to him and then the others please
get to myself please